la première question va être posée par
Madame Anne Laure Blin pour le groupe
les républicains
merci madame le Président Madame le
Premier ministre depuis des semaines
vous évoquez la réforme des retraites
mais vous préoccupez vous vraiment du
bien-être de nos aînés
en vous posant cette question je veux
parler de la fameuse loi grand âge
évoquée par le président en 2018 il y a
déjà 5 ans tellement attendu et qui
aujourd'hui est resté lettres morte la
situation de nos aînés préoccupe toutes
nos familles mais également l'ensemble
des personnels qui ont à cœur de les
accompagner avec bienveillance et
empathie il n'est pas admissible
aujourd'hui que tout soit aussi oublié
que nos soignants soient autant malmenés
car leur métier est un beau et noble
métier il s'occupe des plus fragiles
dans leur quotidien en donnant toute
leur énergie pour à la fois soulager
leur souffrance et aussi parfois leur
solitude
je ne compte plus les témoignages
d'animateurs d'aide-soignant
d'infirmiers d'associations ou encore de
directeurs d'établissements qui me font
part de leur détresse d'une réelle
détresse quant à leur difficulté de
continuer à exercer leur mission avec
humanité nos grands-parents nos parents
méritent que le gouvernement près toute
la mesure de l'enjeu d'une politique
d'ampleur sur ce sujet tous nous devons
nous sentir concernés car toutes les
familles peuvent être confrontées à des
difficultés encore hier la Défenseur des
droits dans son dernier rapport indiqué
que depuis les révélations à scandale du
lien non aucune réponse concrète n'a été
apportée alors ce n'est pas
d'administratif supplémentaire dans les
établissements ont besoin au contraire
ils ont besoin d'une valorisation de ces
six beaux métiers de recrutement massifs
d'investissement majeurs pour répondre
aux demandes et accompagner ceux qui ont
tant donné à la France et qui ont
aujourd'hui besoin de nous alors alors
madame le Premier ministre quand
allez-vous enfin faire du grand âge une
de votre priorité
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Christophe
con ministre des Solidarités de
l'autonomie des personnes handicapées
[Musique]
professionnel le recrutement la
formation favoriser aussi le les
conditions de travail en modernisant nos
EHPAD 2 milliards plus 2 milliards
d'euros sur mobilisés aujourd'hui pour
l'investissement dans les ehpads je suis
d'accord avec vous c'est aujourd'hui une
question sociétale c'est pour ça que
nous avons mis cette question du Bien
vieillir au cœur du Conseil national de
la refondation que nous travaillons à la
fois sur la question de la lutte contre
l'isolement sur la question de la
citoyenneté des personnes âgées sur la
question de l'adaptation de la société
au vieillissement et sur la question des
métiers nous travaillons sans relâche
également pour lutter contre les dérives
du secteur nous avons renforcé les
contrôles 7500 EHPAD seront contrôlés
dans les deux ans qui viennent c'est
pour ça que nous avons également
renforcé la transparence grâce aux
mesures inscrites dans le projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
pour 2023 et que nous lutons sans
relâche contre la maltraitance et
j'ouvrirai dans les jours qui viennent
des Assises de la lutte contre la mal
alors le rapport de la Défenseur des
droits nous invite à accélérer merci
monsieur le ministre
la parole est au président penchère pour
le groupe liotte madame la Première
ministre pour la première fois je
manifesterai ce jeudi contre la réforme
des retraites pour une raison simple
votre réforme est injuste car elle
repose sur le report de l'âge légal de
départ nous avons dit notre désaccord
sur ce constat notre système sera
déficit ces prochaines années mais il
n'est pas en péril nous avons dit notre
désaccord sur la méthode et le
calendrier une réforme menée sans
concertation suffisante et au moment où
les Français souffrent notre désaccord
sur le choix de ne pas laisser le
Parlement prendre le temps d'examiner et
de voter un texte si important notre
désaccord enfin sur vos propositions
vous avez entendu sur les 65 ans c'est
une satisfaction mais 64 ans reste très
injustes le poids de votre réforme
pèsera sur les classes populaires et
moyennes sur celles et ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler tôt toutes ces
injustices ne sont pas comblées par le
positif carrière longue largement
incomplet et vous le savez très peu de
carrière permettront d'accéder à une
retraite minimale 2200 euros madame le
Premier ministre vous nous avez dit que
la concertation continue vous vous
demandons et les Français aussi de
supprimer cette mesure de reportage
légal à 64 ans nous avons déjà parlé de
la nécessité d'un grand plan senior à
quoi cela sert-il d'obliger les gens à
travailler plus longtemps alors qu'ils
sont privés d'emploi c'est ce que disait
le président de la République il y a 5
ans enfin je pose la question de la
recherche de nouveaux financement au
sein même de votre majorité des
propositions apparaissent en résumé
madame la Première ministre pour éviter
une crise sociale majeure allez-vous
enfin écouter les responsables syndicaux
et nos concitoyens
je vous remercie la parole est à madame
la Première ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
président penchère
nous pouvons être en désaccord monsieur
le Président c'est la vie démocratique
mais pour avoir un débat éclairé nous
avons besoin de fait
l'effet c'est que depuis début octobre
les organisations syndicales et
patronales ont été reçus à de multiples
reprises par le ministre du Travail
Olivier du soft et moi-même
l'effet c'est que j'ai rencontré chaque
président de groupe parlementaire à
plusieurs reprises sur ce texte et dans
ce cadre monsieur le Président pencher
nous avons échangé trois fois alors les
faits sont là cette réforme n'a pas été
menée dans la précipitation mais dans la
concertation
nous avons un objectif
préserver notre système par répartition
et là encore l'effet sont têtus le
nombre d'actifs par rapport au nombre de
retraités baisse il y avait deux actifs
pour un retraité en 2005 il y a il y en
a aujourd'hui
1,7 et demain 1,5 nous devons donc
rétablir l'équilibre de notre système de
retraite monsieur le Président pencher
vous me demandez si j'ai des tabous j'ai
plutôt des convictions et des réponses
je suis d'accord avec vous notre système
doit prendre en compte les différences
entre les métiers et entre les carrières
nous voulons un système juste un système
qui tient compte de celles et ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler tôt celles et
ceux qui ont des carrières incomplètes
ou hachées celles et ceux qui ont des
métiers difficiles il serait les
premières victimes d'une absence de
réforme car notre système par
répartition les protège et je le redis
devant vous mesdames et messieurs les
députés notre notre projet est un projet
de justice
celles et ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler tôt
[Applaudissements]
celles et ceux et ceux qui ont commencé
à travailler tôt bénéficieront de départ
anticipés ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler avant 16 ans partiront un an
plus tôt grâce à notre projet et pour
l'ensemble des carrières longues toutes
les personnes ayant une carrière
complète partiront désormais entre deux
ans et 6 ans avant l'âge légal notre
projet prend également en compte la
pénibilité des métiers nous allons tenir
compte de nouveaux facteurs d'usure
professionnelle prendre le tournant de
la prévention favoriser les départs
anticipés pour raison médicale et les
reconversions
j'ajoute que nous serons attentifs au
plus fragile un départ à 62 ans à taux
plein sera possible pour les personnes
en inaptitude en invalidité ou en
incapacité au total quatre Françaises
sur 10 les plus fragiles les plus
modestes celles et ceux qui ont moitié
difficile pourront partir avant 64 ans
et monsieur le Président pencher
s'il vous plaît est-ce que madame la
Première ministre s'exprimer dans le
calme madame Garrido
[Musique]
un peu de silence s'il vous plaît un peu
de silence et monsieur le Président
pencheur vous me parlez des petites
retraites là encore nous sommes au
rendez-vous conformément à l'engagement
du président de la République nous
allons augmenter la retraite minimale
pour une carrière complète au niveau du
SMIC à 85% du SMIC net souhaite une
hausse de 100 euros par mois et ce dès
cette année c'est vrai pour les futurs
retraités comme pour les retraités
actuels au total près de 2 millions de
personnes bénéficieront de cette mesure
dès cette année ce sont pour la plupart
des femmes des commerçants des artisans
c'est une véritable avancée sociale
alors monsieur le Président pencheur ce
projet va préserver l'équilibre de nos
retraites par répartition c'est un
projet de justice pour ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler tôt ou qui
exercent des métiers difficiles c'est un
projet de progrès social pour les plus
fragiles et bien sûr j'espère que la
discussion parlementaire permettra
d'enrichir ce texte je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre
la parole est à Madame Stéphanie Rist
pour le groupe Renaissance merci
monsieur
le ministre du Travail le choix de notre
système de retraite par répartition est
au cœur du pacte social qui unit les
générations il nous appartient
aujourd'hui d'en assurer la pérennité au
travers d'une réforme qui est
indispensable une réforme qui porte une
double ambition assurer la soutenabilité
financière de notre modèle social tout
en le rendant plus juste car nous le
savons face au travail nous ne sommes
pas tous égaux chacun d'entre nous dans
sa circonscription a pu éprouver la
tente vive de nos concitoyens la volonté
de partir à la retraite dans des
conditions dignes et équitables en mai
2021 mes collègues Nicolas turquois et
Lionel cause dans le cadre de leur
mission sur les petites pensions nous
alerter déjà sur les limites de notre
système dans son état actuel parce que
protéger les plus modestes qui ont
travaillé toute leur vie est un
impératif qui à tous notre groupe
Renaissance apporté avec force
l'engagement pris pendant la campagne
législatives revaloriser les petites
pensions de retraite l'annonce de
l'augmentation de la pension minimale a
été faite pour les personnes partant en
retraite à compter du premier septembre
2023 mais également pour ceux qui le
sont déjà aussi un salarié qui a
travaillé au SMIC toute sa vie partira à
la retraite avec une pension de 85% du
SMIC nous avons conscience de l'effort
nécessaire pour le maintien de notre
système ces derniers jours sur le
terrain nous avons tous pu entendre les
craintes de nos concitoyens parce que
chaque carrière est différente savoir
s'ils entrent dans le cadre de ce
dispositif de revalorisation est une
question récurrente monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous nous préciser le contour de
cette mesure
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs députés madame la rapporteur
général Stéphanie Rist vous l'avez dit
pendant la campagne pour les élections
présidentielles le président de la
République s'est engagé engagé à ce que
les petites pensions soient revalorisées
engagées à ce que une vie travaille
donne droit donne lieu à une pension de
retraite qui soit fixée à un niveau des
sons nous avons pris l'engagement que
toute personne ayant cotisé toute sa vie
en une carrière complète au niveau du
SMIC aurait la garantie aura la garantie
d'une retraite égale à 85 % du SMIC
c'est au tour de 1200 euros brut à la
fin de l'année 2023 il y a une vraie
volonté que nous avons de garantir cet
engagement dans le temps c'est la raison
pour laquelle la loi que nous allons
vous présenter dans quelques jours
prévoit un mécanisme d'indexation du
minimum contributif pour faire en sorte
que les 85% du SMIC auquel nous
engageons pour une carrière complète
soit 85% du SMIC au moment de la
liquidation en 2023 comme en 2027 comme
en 2030 et au-delà pour cet engagement
soit véritablement garantie dans le
temps c'est un engagement pour qui ont
cotisé une carrière complète mais bien
évidemment ceux qui n'ont pas une
carrière complète bénéficieront aussi
d'un accroissement de leurs recettes à
du proportion du nombre de trimestres et
d’années qu'ils ont cotisés cela
représente et c'est important presque
200 000 assurés 200000 départs à la
retraite chaque année sur les presque
800000 que compte notre pays 200000
assurés qui vont ainsi voir leur pension
de retraite revaloriser par rapport à la
situation actuelle ça signifie que un
départ à la retraite sur 4 sera mieux
traitée avec ce système qu'il ne l'est
aujourd'hui et évidemment cela concerne
les salariés qui pendant toute leur
carrière ont eu des revenus dans les
trois premiers des cils dans les 30% de
revenus les moins élevés et puis nous
allons tenir un second engagement parce
que vous ne l'avez demandé parce que
d'autres ici sur ces bancs nous l'ont
demandé c'est faire en sorte que les
retraités actuels qui ont une carrière
complète qui ont cotisé plus de 30 ans
puissent aussi bénéficier d'une
revalorisation de leur retraite et nous
le ferons dans les mêmes calendriers les
mêmes termes c'est-à-dire en septembre
2023 et ainsi le double engagement sera
tenu je vous remercie le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Alexis jolie
pour le rassemblement national
merci
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
alors vous lancez en ce début d'année ce
projet de réforme des retraites que le
Président de la République a choisi de
faire figure de grands œuvre de son
quinquennat son objectif faire une
nouvelle fois payer aux Français 40 ans
de faillite politique et morale dans le
quinquennat Macron 1 aura été la
synthèse cette réforme est loin d'être
nécessaire et juste son objectif étant
de rendre impossible départ à la
retraite à taux plein alors comment
feront les jeunes diplômés pour prendre
leur retraite quand le premier emploi
stable se trouve à 27 ans et les non
diplômés qui sont sous la menace du
chômage il n'y aura que des perdants
vous annoncez le départ à 64 ans en
appliquant la méthode des petits pas
dans cinq ans si les Français ont le
malheur de vous voir encore au pouvoir
ce sera 66 ans et puis dans 10 ans
peut-être 68 ans et ce jusqu'à ce que
les Français travaillent jusqu'à la
tombe
la position du rassemblement national et
de Marine Le Pen est claire et assumée
nous défendons la retraite en fonction
de l'âge d'entrée dans la vie active et
alors nous financerons tout cela en
économisant les dizaines de milliards
d'euros que nous coûte chaque année
l'immigration massive ces milliards ces
milliards dépensés qui ne vous posent
guerre de problèmes et puis en
réindustrialisant la France que vos
politiques antinationales ne cessent
d’affaiblir et qui vous pousse à
chercher de nouvelles économies sur le
dos des Français madame la Présidente
cette réforme n'engendra que de
nouvelles souffrances sans pour autant
évidemment régler la question des
déficits alors si vous avez un petit peu
encore de respect et de compassion pour
les Français qu'attendez-vous pour
renoncer à ce projet
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du stop
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député joli vous dites cette réforme des
ni nécessaire ni juste ni nécessaire
c'est une appréciation que nous ne
partageons évidemment pas le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites l'a dit la
répéter en 2027 2027 c'est demain c'est
12,5 milliards d'euros déficit si vous
considérez que 12,5 milliards d'euros de
déficit ça n'est rien ça n'est pas notre
conception des finances publiques ça
n'est pas notre conception de la
responsabilité vous dites que cette
réforme est injuste et tout le contraire
nous protégeons les carrières longues
nous allons mieux protéger la pénibilité
là où votre candidate proposait de
supprimer le compte personnel de
prévention pendant l'élection
présidentielle nous allons augmenter les
petites retraites pour favoriser les
vies de travail valoriser les vies de
labeurs celle dont vous semblait
visiblement vous éloigner et vous
désintéresser la réalité monsieur le
député c'est que pendant la dernière
élection présidentielle votre candidat
est à procédé à deux annonces une
première qu'elle a jugé elle-même
irréaliste un faisable et mal documenté
une deuxième qui visait à corriger et
dans tous les autonomistes ont considéré
que si vous aviez été les deux seules
conséquences auraient été d'aggraver les
déficits et de baisser les pensions pour
les retraités la majorité protège les
députés nous protégeons les pensions des
retraités nous protégeons le pouvoir
d'achat des plus âgés vous êtes là pour
les mettre en danger et je passe sur vos
lubies vos obsessions vos solutions
miracles du côté de l'immigration qui
dénote qu'une chose le rassemblement
national c'est le Front national
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à madame la Présidente
Chatelain pour le groupe écologiste
merci Madame madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre les
retraites sont le cœur de notre modèle
social français alors je vous le demande
nous reproduisons pas dans nos débats
les quatre types qui ne représentent
personne sauf les statistiques agrégé à
puridor par vos cabinets de conseils et
transformer en visuels réseaux sociaux
par vos communicants vendredi j'étais à
Vizille dans ma circonscription j'ai
rencontré une ancienne une ancienne
aide-soignante qui aujourd'hui 58 ans et
donc je préfère taire le nom lors d'un
dépistage elle lui a diagnostiqué un
cancer du sein elle a pourtant continué
à travailler jusqu'à ce qu'elle ne
puisse plus et se mettre en arrêt longue
maladie en 2018 aujourd'hui elle veut
retrouver du boulot mais elle ne se
sentait pas de reprendre son métier
d'aide-soignante tant il est
physiquement éprouvant elle a donc fait
une formation en secrétariat mais depuis
11 mois elle se désespère de trouver un
travail à chaque entretien on lui
demande pourquoi les trous dans son CV
pourquoi ça réorientation et il est en
concurrence avec des personnes qui ont
la moitié de son âge allez-vous venir à
Vizille ou à Grenoble pour s'assurer que
les entreprises jouent bien de jeu de
l'index seniors aujourd'hui c'est 56%
des 55 64 ans qui était en emploi en
France au 4e trimestre 2021 ce sont les
chiffres de la DARES c'est votre échec
c'est celui de l'emploi des 55 ans vous
voulez allonger la durée de cotisations
et reculer l'âge de départ de la
retraite mais vous ne proposez rien aux
femmes de 55 ans et plus éloigné de
l'emploi et qui à cause de vous subiront
le chômage et la décote et vous osez
parler de progrès social mais pour qui
madame la Première ministre alors je
pourrais vous souffler une réponse vous
voulez faire 18 milliards d'euros
d'économies sur les 55 65 ans pour obéir
au dogue des 3% du pack de stabilité ce
pacte qui met à genoux nos économies qui
met à mal notre industrie qui menace nos
démocraties et nos modèles sociaux
je vous remercie
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la Présidente là comme vous tous les
jours je rencontre des situations
difficiles comme celle de
l'aide-soignante que vous avez évoquée
évidemment nous devons être
particulièrement attentifs à des
personnes dans des situations difficiles
je pense que nous devons être beaucoup
plus ambitieux sur la façon dont nous
accompagnons les seniors dans le retour
à l'emploi et je peux vous assurer que
le ministre du Travail que le ministre
du Travail dans le cadre des
concertations qu'il a pu engager sur
France travail cherche à trouver le
meilleur chemin pour ramener vers
l'emploi toutes les personnes en
difficulté mais madame la Présidente
Chatelain nous avons par ailleurs un
enjeu majeur pour notre modèle social de
rétablir l'équilibre de notre système de
retraite parce que les personnes
fragiles les personnes modestes que dont
vous nous citer les exemples un exemple
que le ministre du Travail qu'évidemment
mon gouvernement est que moi-même je
vois
peuvent aujourd'hui s'appuyer sur un
système de retraite par répartition et
un système de répartition madame la
Présidente quand le nombre d'actifs et
désolé c'est une statistique quand le
nombre d'actifs qui financent une
pension quand on a deux actifs pour
financer la pension d'un retraité en
2005 1,7 aujourd'hui 1,5 demain je
voudrais que vous m'expliquer quel est
le chemin quelle est l'alternative à la
réforme que nous portons à la réforme
que nous portons de demander en effet
aux Français collectivement de
travailler progressivement plus
longtemps et nous le faisons madame la
Présidente Chatelain je tiens à le dire
en portant une volonté de justice et de
progrès de justice parce que nous
prenons en compte la situation des
personnes qui ont commencé à travailler
tôt et nous améliorons le dispositif
carrière longue je le disais aujourd'hui
quand vous êtes quand vous avez commencé
à travailler tôt vous pouvez partir à de
départ légal voir deux ans avant l'âge
de départ demain c'est deux ans ou 6 ans
avant l'âge de départ nous prenons en
compte la situation de tous ceux qui
sont en inaptitude en incapacité en
invalidité nous prenons en compte la
situation de ceux qui ont des métiers
difficiles au-delà des critères du
compte professionnel pénibilité et nous
voulons par ailleurs améliorer la
situation des retraités de demain et
d'aujourd'hui et c'est pour ça que nous
avons porté conformément aux engagements
du Président de la République une
revalorisation des pensions minimales
pour atteindre 85% du SMIC net quand
vous avez eu une carrière complète donc
oui madame la Présidente vous avez
raison derrière les chiffres ce sont des
cas personnels ce sont ces personnes
auxquelles nous portons attention et
dont nous voulons améliorer la vie
professionnelle et la retraite je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre madame la Présidente Chatelain
madame la Première ministre personne
n'est dupe de vos événements de manga
tout le monde connaît l'impact que ça
rate sur le vie et les Français le 19
seront dans la rue pour vous le rappeler
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame
Marianne Maximy pour le groupe la France
insoumise merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre il y a une semaine le
gouvernement annoncé son intention de
repousser l'âge de la retraite à 64 ans
depuis la liste des grands perdants de
cette réforme ne cessent de s'allonger
les plus pauvres d'abord hier premier de
corvée ils sont aujourd'hui en première
ligne de votre brutalité sociale les
femmes ensuite celles que vous avez
applaudis pendant la pandémie parce que
leur salaire sont plus bas qu'elles
subissent des temps partiels imposées et
le chômage toute mesure d'âge les
pénalise doublement et aggravent les
inégalités de genre
alors où sont les grands gagnants comme
toujours avec vous ce sont les plus
riches la facture pour le grand patronat
sera de 0 euro vous égarez vous écartez
toute idée de hausse des cotisations
patronales vous maintenez des crédits
d'impôts inutiles et autres exonérations
qui appauvrissent notre système de
solidarité
pour les grandes fortunes de ce pays
aussi la facture est à zéro euro
pourtant leur enrichissement grâce à la
crise explose tous les plafonds Oxfam le
révélé hier depuis 2020 les
milliardaires français ont augmenté leur
fortune de plus de
58%. Oxfam montre qu'il suffirait de
taxer ces milliardaires à 2% pour
financer le déficit supposé des
retraites qui vous préoccupent de temps
ils ont même tellement accumulé que cela
permettrait d'équilibrer le régime des
retraites pendant au moins 20 ans et
même accrochez-vous de quoi abaisser
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite mais
vous continuez d'écarter toute
augmentation des impôts pour ces
ultra-riches finalement votre réforme
n'a rien d'économique elle est purement
idéologique une idéologie du malheur où
il faut travailler jusqu'à la mort pour
qu'une poignée s'enrichisse toujours
plus votre réforme fait l'unanimité
contre vous l'ensemble des syndicats 80%
de la population française renfort
refuse votre réforme et même 45% de
votre propre électorat madame la
Première ministre vous êtes extrêmement
minoritaire ma question est simple
qu'attendez-vous pour renoncer merci
beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion merci madame la
présidente madame la députée Massimi je
vais reprendre le début de votre
question vous dites votre réforme va
faire deux perdants les plus pauvres et
les femmes vous verrez madame la députée
que dans l'étude d'impact qui a comparé
gras le projet de loi vous pouvez le
voir aussi dans les documents que nous
avons rendu public avec madame la
Première ministre que la réforme que
nous portons ajustement les effets
inverse de ceux que vous décrivez les
salariés les retraités qui vont
connaître la meilleure amélioration de
retraite par cette réforme que ce soit
par l'application du minimum de garantie
que ce soit par l'augmentation moyen du
niveau des retraites du fait de
l'allongement de la cotisation ce sont
les salariés qui gagnent un salaire dans
les trois premiers des cils les 30% de
salariés les plus modestes qui vont
bénéficier d'une augmentation 5 fois
supérieure aux autres catégories de
population les femmes vont être mieux
protégées mieux protégés parce que nous
ne reculons pas à l'âge de suppression
de la décote mieux protéger parce que
l'application de la retraite minimum va
plus se protéger 20 plus bénéficier aux
femmes qu'aux hommes mieux protéger
aussi puisque nous allons intégrer dans
l'éligibilité au minimum de retraite au
dispositif de carrière longue les
trimestres qui sont cotisés au titre de
l'assurance vieillesse et donc du congé
parental autant d'avancer auquel vous
n'avez jamais pensé ok vous n'avez
jamais songé cette réforme va protéger
les plus fragiles et va protéger les
femmes madame la députée il y a une
chose de sûr puisque vous parlez de
jeudi dernier manifester une opposition
un désaccord si la démocratie inciter
les gens à manifester en leur mentant en
exagérant en étant entonnant des propos
tronciers en expliquant qu'on va
travailler jusqu'à la mort c'est de la
manipulation c'est faire peu de cas de
la dignité de ce que vous appelez à
manifester
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Madame violette
spielbaux pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre dans ma circonscription à
Mouvaux près de Lille nous étions tous
très inquiets pour l'avenir de
l'entreprise carlide fabricant français
de poche de perfusion et de ses 450
salariés vous le savez malgré un soutien
fort de l'État depuis des années avec
plus de 10 millions d'aides publiques
reçues depuis 2020 carlide avait été
néanmoins contrainte d'ouvrir une
procédure de redressement judiciaire fin
octobre 2022 dès lors avec la région des
Hauts de France la métropole européenne
de Lille le maire de Mouvaux les
organisations syndicales et l'État nous
nous sommes unis et démenés pour trouver
un repreneur industriel jusqu'à ce
vendredi jusqu'au dernier moment nous
attendions une offre et aujourd'hui nous
pouvons nous réjouir de l'offre de
reprise elle est extrêmement sérieuse
réalisée par le groupe d'elfarm et les
laboratoires agains groupes industriels
français spécialisé dans le biomédical
et déjà présent dans la métropole
lilloise Alice les Lannoy aujourd'hui
grâce à vous nous prenons espoir c'est
une très belle étape je tiens à cet
effet monsieur le ministre à vous
remercier ainsi que dans l'ensemble de
vos équipes mobilisées depuis plusieurs
mois pour à la fois sauvegarder le
savoir-faire français et contribuer à la
souveraineté sanitaire c'est un
véritable travail de fond bien loin des
gesticulations et des coups de
communication
monsieur le ministre je sais pouvoir
compter sur votre engagement et celui du
ministre de la Santé aussi les
prochaines étapes qui permettront de
sauver définitivement carlide et ses 450
employés je vous en remercie
merci beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Roland Lescure ministre délégué en
charge de l'Industrie
madame la Présidente
mesdames messieurs les députés madame la
députée violette spielboot bravo
et merci
parce que madame la députée loin des
gesticulations vous l'avez dit des uns
des autres loin des youtubeurs de la
discorde et de la défaite vous n'avez
rien lâché vous n'avez rien lâché nous
n'avons rien lâché vous êtes resté aux
côtés des salariés de carlide vous êtes
resté aussi à nos côtés pour nous
accompagner accompagner dans mes
services dans les efforts qu'ils ont
fait jour et nuit pour trouver un
repreneur et vous l'avez dit nous avons
trouvé un repreneur de qualité madame la
députée lundi dernier fait Open en
Savoie a annoncé la reprise de son site
industriel par
ugitech jeudi dernier j'étais dans
l'Oise un industrie à l'Américain
kemmour a annoncé 180 millions
d'investissements 80 en poils à clé pour
réindustrialiser investir dans les
membranes d'hydrogène vendredi vous
l'avez dit
un repreneur d'extrême qualité annoncé à
déposer une offre ferme pour carlide
hier madame la députée j'étais dans le
Nord et dans le Pas-de-Calais pour
annoncer des investissements extrêmement
forts dans la décarbonation de notre
industrie madame la députée tout ceci
n'arrive pas par hasard c'est la
politique industrielle portée par le
Président de la République soutenu par
cette majorité que j'ai l'honneur de
porter avec Bruno Le Maire qui nous
permet d'engranger ces bonnes nouvelles
dans un environnement extrêmement
contraint cette politique industrielle
nous allons continuer à la mettre en
œuvre nous allons continuer à travailler
avec le repreneur pour que cette offre
soit définitive et nous allons le faire
malgré les cris d'orfray de celles et
ceux qui font leur beurre politique sur
les déficits et les défaites de
l'économie depuis trop d'années merci
madame la députée
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Nicolas sensu pour
le groupe gauche de démocrate et
républicaine merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre mes chers
collègues 64 ans avec 43 années de
cotisation le verdict est tombé nos
compatriotes seraient appelés si vous
n'entendez pas l'opposition unanime de
tous les syndicats de salariés et plus
de 3/4 de la population à travailler
plus longtemps quelle ineptie cette
offensive de votre part qui répond aux
injonctions de Bruxelles ne sont pas de
stabilité est inutile injuste et
inefficace
inutile car le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites souligne qu'il n'y a pas de
dynamique non contrôlée des dépenses de
retraite mieux en 2022 le système est
excédentaire de plus de 3 milliards
d'euros injuste car ce seront les
salariés les plus modestes et d'abord
les femmes qui vont encore y perdre leur
espérance de vie en bonne santé va
continuer de diminuer et plus d'un
million de nos compatriotes entre 55 et
64 ans seront dans une grande un
locataire du RSA ou en invalidité
inefficace car s'il s'agit de trouver
huit à 9 milliards d'euros les 80
milliards d'euros de dividendes versés
par les entreprises du CAC 40 sont là
pour nous rappeler qu'un autre partage
des richesses est possible alors alors
que les Français nos entreprises les
collectivités locales subissent
l'explosion des coûts de l'énergie
l'inflation galopante imposée ce recul
c'est agrandir la fracturation de notre
société c'est une faute politique c'est
dangereux pour la cohésion de notre pays
madame la Première ministre en une
semaine vous n'avez pas réussi à
convaincre vous êtes ultra minoritaire
dans le pays vous n'avez pas le choix
l'esprit de responsabilité vous oblige
il n'y a qu'une alternative retrait ou
référendum dans tous les cas les députés
communistes et ultramarins du groupe de
la Gauche démocrate et républicaine
s'engageront pleinement auprès de notre
peuple mobilisé rendez-vous dès ce jeudi
dans toutes les villes de France
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier du soft ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Député sans sucre
j'entends votre question et il y a un
point que je ne m'explique pas mais je
vais le partager avec vous c'est l'idée
que cette réforme ne serait pas
nécessaire le Conseil d'orientation des
retraites vous le savez comme moi est
composé des partenaires sociaux l'État
ne votent pas au sein du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites le Conseil
travaille plusieurs hypothèses plusieurs
conventions et autour de ce qu'on
appelle l'hypothèse centrale qui est
l'hypothèse qui a toujours été retenue
pour examiner le système de retraite il
y a un déficit qui se creuse à horizon
2027 je partage l'idée que le système
est légèrement excédentaire en 2021 2022
c'est un constat il est déficitaire dès
2023 le déficit se creuse 12 milliards 5
en 2027 presque 15 milliards en 2030 25
milliards d'euros en 2040 c'est cette
nécessité à laquelle il faut répondre et
cette nécessité s'explique par le fait
tout simplement que nous sommes moins
nombreux à cotiser par rapport de
retraités à la fin des années 70 c'était
trois actifs qui cotisaient pour un
retraité aujourd'hui c'est un peu plus
d'un an et demi et donc nous avons cette
nécessité de tenir le système vous nous
dites ça serait une erreur de maintenir
la réforme l'erreur serait de la retirer
parce que la retirer serait mettre en
danger le système par répartition auquel
vous et moi nous sommes attachés comme
la quasi-totalité des banques cette
émission nous avons un objectif que nous
partageons que nous expliquons avec la
première ministre qui est à la fois
d'améliorer et d'équilibrer le système
l'améliorer en apportant de nouveaux
droits et sans mes estimer à aucun
moment les désaccords que nous pouvons
avoir avec le président Chassaigne nous
vous allons dans cette dans ce projet de
loi permettre aussi d'améliorer les
dispositifs dont il était à l'initiative
l'équilibré parce que c'est nécessaire
si nous nous contentons de l'améliorer
son équilibré ça n'est pas responsable
si nous l'équilibrons ça l'améliore ça
l'améliorer ça n'est pas juste et nous
faisons les deux avec ce projet dont
nous avons l'occasion de débattre
ensemble
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur sangsue
les Français vous le montreront après
demain
je vous remercie monsieur le député la
parole est à Madame Anne Le Hénaff pour
le groupe horizon merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à la
ministre de l'Enseignement supérieur et
de la Recherche madame la ministre le 9
décembre dernier je suis allé à la
rencontre des étudiants et élèves de
l'institut de formation en profession de
santé de Vannes dans ma circonscription
lors de ces échanges j'ai été alerté par
la différence de statues entre les
étudiants infirmiers qui ont le statut
étudiant et les élèves aide-soignants et
être puéricultrices qui ont le statut
élève ces derniers qui représentent un
tiers des effectifs en IFPS sont en
situation précaire financièrement en
effet lors du précédent quinquennat il a
été conféré le statut étudiant aux
jeunes en formation infirmiers leur
donnant ainsi accès aux avantages
sociaux économiques dont bénéficié les
autres étudiants de France toutefois
cette élargissement ne concerne pas les
élèves aide-soignants et aide
puéricultrice relevant du statut élève
ils ne peuvent prétendre à aucun de ses
avantages ce qui crée une véritable
situation d'injustice entre ces jeunes
alors même qu'ils sont dans la même
école à titre d'exemple un étudiant
infirmier pèse son repas 3,6 € au CROUS
alors qu'un élève aide-soignant devra le
payer 8 euros n'ayant pas de carte
étudiante ils n'ont pas accès au tarif
réduit dans les transports en commun ni
dans les cinémas ils ne sont pas
éligibles non plus au logement du CROUS
ils sont également privés d'une médecine
préventive au sein d'une université ces
élèves ne demandent pas le statut
étudiant mais une revalorisation de
leurs conditions leur permettant de
vivre sereinement leur formation et ce
d'autant plus que le constate un fort
taux d'abandon dans ses filières à
l'heure où l'inflation attend plus de 5%
et où l'accès au logement se durcit il
nous faut soutenir ses élèves et
susciter des vocations notre hôpital a
besoin de ses futurs personnels
soignants ainsi madame la ministre
quelle mesure le gouvernement entend
prendre pour revaloriser le statut de
ses élèves en IFPS je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la députée la
parole est à Madame Sylvie Retailleau
ministre de l'Enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche
madame la Présidente Monsieur Madame les
députés madame
tout d'abord merci pour votre question
cette votre question qui porte sur
effectivement l'égalité d'accès en
particulier à la restauration pour tous
les étudiants et à une offre sociale et
aussi l'Université des formations
paramédicales alors je voudrais d'abord
vous dire que c'est un enjeu pour nous
et que nous y travaillons depuis mon
arrivée je vais le développer je
voudrais vous rappeler d'abord le
principe général effectivement vous
l'avez dit qui permet à toute étudiant
qui sont inscrits dans des formations du
supérieur d'avoir accès à l'offre des
CROUS que ce soit offre de restauration
ou offre de logements mais effectivement
toutes les formations ne sont pas des
formations dites du supérieur ou
post-bac c'est le cas donc nous avons
universatarisé les formations
infirmières il y a quelques temps ce qui
leur permet d'avoir accès de droits à la
restauration au tarif social de 3,30 €
motivation précaire et aujourd'hui les
formations sanitaires et sociales
dépendent des régions et sont sous la
responsabilité des régions pour autant
nous ne pouvons pas laisser ces
étudiants ou élève sans accès à la
restauration ou d'autres et c'est
pourquoi nous avons travaillé à des
conventionnements avec le CROUS par
exemple les collectivités peuvent faire
des conventionnements avec le CROUS pour
que ces élèves qui ne sont pas étudiants
dans le supérieur pour l'instant ou
puisse avoir accès à la restauration du
CROUS à tarif social nous avons augmenté
dans la loi de finances 2023 le budget
lié à ses conventionnements dans mon
ministère de plus 33% pour pouvoir
travailler avec les collectivités à
développer ses conventionnnements et à
pouvoir donner accès à ces élèves quel
que soit aujourd'hui leur statut au
niveau du CROUS et à même tarification
que les étudiants c'est un travail que
l'on continue à avec mes équipes sur
lesquelles les régions qui sont en
responsabilité doivent se rapprocher
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
la parole est à Madame Alexandra Martin
pour le groupe les républicains
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
garde des sceaux l'augmentation de la
part des mineurs de plus en plus jeunes
dans la délinquance notamment par des
faits de violences physiques et dans la
criminalité est aujourd'hui un constat
que l'on ne peut plus ignorer le drame
que constitue le décès de cette
adolescent de 16 ans poignardé au thorax
ainsi que la grave blessure de son
camarade aux abords de leur lycée à
Thiais dans le Val-de-Marne ne doit plus
se reproduire nous pensons à cet instant
à la douleur de leur famille
d'après les premières précisions du
procureur il s'agit d'un conflit de
bande c'est fait d'une violence extrême
se multiplie dans notre société prouvant
l'incapacité des pouvoirs publics
endiguer ce phénomène ces jeunes en
perte de repères et d'autorité nous ne
répondent plus qu'à leur loi à la loi de
leur bande ou de leur clan se moquant
des conséquences de leurs actes nous
sommes bien aujourd'hui au delà de ce
qui relève de l'émotion suscité par de
telles comportements mais bien face à un
véritable défi sociétal et
civilisationnel celui de l'autorité pour
que chacun puisse vivre librement dans
une société plus sûre et celui de la
responsabilité pour que la culture de
l'excuse ne soit plus la règle si la
prévention est nécessaire elle doit être
couplée à la répression en accord avec
les réflexions et les propositions
formulées par le président de la MF
David Lisnard qui dresse avec les mers
le constat de l'augmentation de ses
faits de délinquance dans leur commune
j'ai rédigé une proposition de loi en
voyant la levée de l'application des
règles d'atténuation des peines dès
l'âge de 13 ans pour les faits les plus
graves l'abaissement de l'excuse de
minorité à 20% de la peine encourue et
l'instauration d'une nouvelle infraction
autonome de celle imputable au mineur
qui engagerait la responsabilité des
parents en effet face à un sentiment
d'impunité il est urgent de rétablir
l'autorité de l'État l'autorité de la
police l'autorité de la justice de
l'école et des parents
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre ne
croyez-vous pas qu'il est indispensable
d'adapter le code pénal des mineurs à la
réalité de ce fléau grandissant merci
merci ma chère collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Eric Dupont-Moretti garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice
oui madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Alexandra Martin oui que le sang de nos
enfants coule sur le trottoir pour une
cigarette pour un mot pour un regard
vous avez raison c'est absolument
insupportable
la loi nous l'avons modifié nous l'avons
modifié ensemble c'est le code de
justice pénal des mineurs il y a un peu
plus d'un an de cela je rappelle que ici
à l'Assemblée nationale les LR votre
famille à voter ce texte le Sénat a fait
de même les premiers résultats c'est que
un mineur sur deux était jugé quand il
était majeur aujourd'hui c'est dans un
délai de neuf mois que la décision
intervient par ailleurs madame la
députée les interdictions de paraître
outils qui marchent bien j'ai demandé au
procureur généraux de faire en sorte
dans ma dernière politique dans ma
dernière circulaire de politique
générale de plus de davantage appliqué
cet outil enfin la mise en place dans
les grandes villes de groupement locaux
de traitement de la délinquance
et je voudrais vous dire que
contrairement à ce que vous affirmez
dans certaines grandes agglomérations ce
phénomène de bande à diminuer j'ai voulu
ce que vous proposiez je dois dire que
en l'état de notre droit c'est
parfaitement satisfait et je veux vous
rappeler qu'en matière de justice pénale
des mineurs l'atténuation de
responsabilité
issue du Conseil national de résistance
du général de Gaulle est un principe
madame la députée à valeur
constitutionnelle consacrée par le
Conseil constitutionnel et le droit
actuel permet déjà de lever l'excuse de
minorité à 16 ans sur décision du juge
ma ligne est claire en la matière
fermeté sans démagogie humanisme sans
angélisme je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier Faure pour le groupe socialiste
madame
[Applaudissements]
la présidente
s'il vous plaît
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
madame la Première ministre
est-il oui ou non selon vous juste que
celles et ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler le plus tôt ont eu les plus
pénibles on l'espérance de vie la plus
courte et à cotiser plus longtemps que
celles et ceux qui ont travaillé plus
tard ont eu les métiers les moins
pénibles et les moins usants et on
l'espérance de vie la plus longue
Monsieur Olivier du soft ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion monsieur madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Député fort
le 4 janvier dans une interview
libération vous avez dit être favorable
à la retraite à 60 ans vous mettant une
fois de plus dans la roue de la France
insoumise mais vous avez dit en
maintenant les 43 années de cotisation
est-ce que vous êtes favorable à ce qui
est une machine à décote et à petite
pension
merci monsieur le ministre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le député
je vous ai connu une autre époque où
vous défendiez effectivement les
Français qui ont commencé à travailler
tour vous défendiez celles et ceux qui
le matin se lèvent aux aurores prennent
le RER ou le bus celle qui vide nos
poubelles celles et ceux qui sont caries
cette soignantes etc celles et ceux qui
effectivement n'avait que vous pour les
défendre et vous les avez oublié vous
êtes aujourd'hui de celles et ceux qui
allaient défendre un projet de loi ou
celles et ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler entre 14 et 20 ans auront à
cotisé car en quatre années quand tous
les autres le roi que 43 ans voilà ce
que vous défendez aujourd'hui
je ne suis pas là votre tête ni dans
votre peau mais j'ai honte pour vous on
discute défendez aujourd'hui honte de
voir que vous avez renié l'ensemble de
vos projets je vous ai connu avec Henri
Emmanuelli je vous ai connu avec Martine
Aubry et je vous vois aujourd'hui dans
ce gouvernement faire en sorte de faire
de rogner complètement ce que vous avez
jusqu'ici été l'apôtre du progrès social
alors voilà effectivement ce que je
regrette et je vois que dans votre
propre majorité ça se fracture parce
qu'il y a des gens qui aujourd'hui
comprennent que vous êtes minorita dans
ce pays et que dans ce pays nous serons
des millions à défiler jeudi
je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre
monsieur le député fort
seul député fort vous savez que les
effets de manche pour être applaudis par
un peu moins de la moitié de vos groupes
si j'ai bien compté les effets de manche
ne marche pas les procès entrahon je
suis immunisé surtout quand ils viennent
par ceux qui ont vendu la sociale
démocratie à l'extrême gauche pour
sauver l'ancienne vous détendez la
retraite à 60 ans avec 43 ans vous allez
appauvrir les retraités vous êtes dans
la roue de la France insoumise vous vous
faites marcher dessus par Jean-Luc
Mélenchon si les sociaux-démocrates qui
pour vous devrez avoir honte vous avez
en réalité aucun intérêt pour les
Français ne sont l'intérêt que vous avez
c'est pour votre congrès
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
alors s'il vous plaît un peu de calme la
parole est à Monsieur
Erwan Balanant pour le gros démocrate
merci madame la Présidente
s'il vous plaît
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse la question de notre
jeunesse est pluriel tant elle
représente notre diversité et notre
héritage elle est aussi la clé de voûte
de la société de demain mais aujourd'hui
quel avenir lui offrons-nous je sais que
cette question vous anime tout autant
que moi c'est pourquoi plus que d'y
réfléchir philosophiquement nous devons
d'y répondre concrètement
sans tomber dans les excès et les
raccourcis notre jeunesse nous expose
quotidiennement ses attentes ses peurs
et sa colère sa colère contre une
société qui détruit sa nature contre une
société où l'homophobie et les
discriminations existent encore une
société où les violents ou les jeunes
victimes et auteurs font face à de la
violence dans leur quotidien
l'actualité nous le rappelle encore
aujourd'hui et nous montre l'impact
qu'elle peut avoir sur leur comportement
et leur confiance il y a 5 ans déjà je
m'exprimais à ce même micro face à un
ministre différent certes mais sur le
même sujet si depuis 5 ans nous avons
nous pouvons noter plusieurs avancées
sur le harcèlement le code pénal des
mineurs le droit des enfants il est
toujours heureux pour moi de constater
qu'il y a encore tant à faire alors
Monsieur le Ministre donnant un coup de
pouce à cette jeunesse donnant lui
confiance en l'avenir car il y a une
qualité de que cette jeunesse garde
toujours c'est sa capacité à refuser un
futur incertain son optimisme et sa
persévérance redonne espoir
mobilisons-nous nous devons nous nous
devons de la protéger et de lui
permettre de s'épanouir et de
s'émanciper ces notes devoir d'adultes
mais c'est surtout notre responsabilité
d'hommes et de femmes politiques et
l'État doit être en être le garant
notre jeunesse peut-être avoir confiance
en l'état
nos institutions sont-elles toujours en
phase avec ses attentes
quelle grande politique de protection de
prévention et d'accompagnement devant
nous mettre en place monsieur le
ministre Créon pour notre avenir une
grande politique de la jeunesse
je vous remercie monsieur le député la
parole est à Monsieur papenda ministre
de l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le députés Balanant ces
derniers jours
ont été malheureusement marqués par la
mort de deux élèves et mes pensées vont
bien entendu mes pensées ému vont
d'abord à leur famille à leurs proches
et à leurs parents le jeune Lucas a été
victime de harcèlement en raison de son
homosexualité cette situation avait été
identifiée prise en charge par son
collège mais cela n'a pas suffi à
l'évidence l'enquête déterminera les
causes et les circonstances exactes de
son suicide ainsi que les
responsabilités de chacun ce drame
mesdames et messieurs les députés
montrent à quel point la lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire doit demeurer une
priorité du gouvernement la loi que vous
avez portée monsieur le député on a fait
un délit et accentuer la prise de
conscience de ce phénomène nous avons à
la rentrée généralisée le programme
phare dans toutes les écoles
élémentaires et tous les collèges mais
il est vrai qu'il nous reste encore
beaucoup pas faire tant sur le plan de
la lutte contre le harcèlement que du
point de vue de la lutte contre les
l'homophobies c'est pour cela que j'ai
décidé dans les prochaines semaines que
devait être généralisé des groupes de
sensibilisation et de prévention contre
les LGBT phobies la haine anti LGBT est
absolument intolérable que ce soit à
l'école ou en dehors
[Musique]
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Aurélien Lopez
ligori pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'Économie des Finances aujourd'hui sur
ma circonscription au Super U d'Agde les
agathatois payent un euro 85 le litre
d'essence en moyenne les français payent
leur carburant entre 1,80 et 2 euros le
litre cette situation est intenable la
France rurale souffre la France qui
travaille suffoque sur ce sujet comme
sur tant d'autres votre gouvernement
colmate fini la resourne de 30 centimes
voici maintenant le chèque carburant qui
va concerner une minorité de français
hier en une journée puis 850 000 d'entre
eux ont demandé ce chèque provoquant
l'indécente satisfaction de Monsieur
Attal comment peut-on être à ce point
déconnecté de la réalité pour se réjouir
de la manifestation la plus éclatante de
la précarité des Français vous les
obligez à venir mendier pour 100 euros
soit un plein par an
de plus depuis novembre le prix du baril
brut baisse tandis que le prix à la
pompe augmente deux possibilités soit
les énergéticiens se gavent sur le dos
des Français alors le refus de l'extrême
gauche nupèche et de la majorité de
voter notre proposition de taxation des
super profits est une trahison soit
c'est vous l'État qui vous gavait et
dans ce cas vous êtes les artisans de la
case sociale d'ailleurs en parlant de
cas social vous préférez avancer votre
injuste réforme des retraites vous
prenez le risque de provoquer une
nouvelle crise dans les raffineries vous
entraînez les Français vers de nouvelles
pénuries oui vous jetez de l'huile sur
le feu et ce sont les Français qui en
font les frais alors Monsieur le
Ministre Cannes mettez-vous que l'unique
solution à cette crise et la baisse de
la TVA à 5,5 sur l'essence le fioul
l'électricité et le gaz comme le propose
Marine Le Pen depuis des mois
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'Économie des Finances de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs
députés monsieur le député Lopez la
mesure que vous proposez de baisse de la
TVA ou qu'elle ira directement dans la
poche de distributeurs et pas des
consommateurs coûte 12 milliards d'euros
pour amortir l'inflation là où cette
majorité a dépensé près de 50 milliards
d'euros avec le bouclier énergétique
pour protéger les Français contre
l'inflation vous leur proposez quelques
centimes d'euros et des miettes nous ne
leur proposons 180 à 200 euros
d'économie en moyenne par mois sur la
facture de gaz et sur la facture de
l'électricité les Français jugeront où
se trouvent la justice et où se trouve
l'efficacité de notre côté et du côté de
cette majorité c'est bien pour cela que
nous avons que vous le vouliez ou non
depuis deux ans le taux d'inflation le
plus faible de tous les pays de la zone
euro c'est bien pour ça que nous avons
protégé contre l'augmentation des prix
du carburant et si vous teniez de temps
à cette remise de 30 centimes d'euros et
bien il fallait voter le budget qui
permettait de la financer c'est bien
pour cela qu'avec la première ministre
nous avons mis en place une indemnité
carburant travailleur qui en 48 heures a
été sollicitée par 1,3 millions de nos
compatriotes justice et efficacité c'est
bien pour cela que nous garantissons un
prix moyen de la facture de
l'électricité à 280 € de mégawattheure
pour toutes les très petits entreprises
justice et efficacité et c'est pour cela
que nous maintiendrons notre bouclier
gergétique en 2023 pour protéger nos
compatriotes justice et efficacité
contre l'inflation voilà les résultats
que nous représentez à nos compatriotes
je vous remercie monsieur le député le
ministre nous étions les seuls à
demander la ristourne pour le budget
2023 le seul groupe je vous remercie
la parole est à madame la Présidente
katabi pour le groupe Renaissance merci
bien Madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre il y a un peu moins d'un an
nous découvrions avec stupeur la
maltraitance subit par nos aînés dans
certains EHPAD au travers des
révélations du journaliste Victor
Castanet cette honte de choc il faut le
rappeler à définitivement marqué un
tournant aussi face à la gravité des
faits j'avais alors immédiatement
déclenché au sein de la commission des
affaires sociales tout un cycle
d'audition avec comme objectif de
permettre à la représentation nationale
de faire toute la lumière sur cette
affaire et d'entendre l'ensemble des
acteurs concernés à commencer par les
dirigeants du groupe d'EHPAD mise en
cause de ces travaux parlementaires à
découler un rapport dont les
préconisations ont été entendues par le
gouvernement notamment en ce qui
concerne renforcement des contrôles je
remercie à ce sujet votre prédécesseur
Brigitte bourguignon pour sa réactivité
et son engagement et je salue également
votre action monsieur le ministre car je
sais que vous veillez à la poursuite du
plan de contrôle qui est prévu dans les
7500 EHPAD sur les deux ans en effet la
majorité parlementaire avec le soutien
continue d'agir pour renforcer les
moyens consacrés à la politique du grand
âge que ce soit au travers de la
dernière loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale avec le recrutement
prévu de 50000 professionnels en EHPAD
ou encore avec la proposition de loi
déposée par la majorité un texte combien
attendu et qui sera débattu dans les
prochaines semaines nous le savons il
reste encore beaucoup pas faire pour
pouvoir accompagner nos aînés dans la
dignité c'est notamment la conclusion du
dernier rapport de la Défenseur des
droits sur le sujet aussi face aux défis
qu'il nous faut relever pour
pourriez-vous monsieur le ministre nous
indiquez quel est le bilan des actions
mises en oeuvre depuis un an et les
mesures qui seront prochainement
déployés je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Christophe con ministre des
Solidarités de l'autonomie et des
personnes handicapées madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales vous
évoquez une onde de choc cette onde de
choc nous l'avons tous ressenti c'est la
l'enquête approfondie de Victor Castanet
qui arrivait les choses qui ont
profondément choqué les Français et qui
m'ont profondément choqué à cette prise
de conscience collective on succédé à un
certain nombre d'actions vous en avez
cité un certain nombre à l'initiative
des pouvoirs publics et en particulier à
l'initiative de la Commission que vous
présidez et je vous en remercie le
rapport récent de la Défenseur des
droits nous permet aujourd'hui de faire
un bilan de l'ensemble de ces actions
c'est d'abord la régulation du secteur
nous avons mis en place un plan de
contrôle global de l'ensemble des 7500
EHPAD dans les deux ans nous avons
d'ores et déjà contrôlé près de 2000 et
2000 EHPAD 700 d'entre eux ont déjà fait
l'objet de contrôle approfondi ce qu'on
appelle des inspections contrôle sur
pièce sur place de façon inopinée ou de
façon programmée et ont donné un certain
nombre de résultats 650 injonctions et
recommandations cette saisine du
procureur de la République pour des
faits qui relèvent du pénal nous avons
saisi le procureur mais on va pas
évidemment s'arrêter là vous l'avez dit
je voudrais insister sur trois sujets le
premier celui du taux d'encadrement dans
les EHPAD vous l'avez dit on a lancé
cette année le recrutement de 50000
nouveaux professionnels dans les EHPAD
pour renforcer ce taux d'encadrement et
nous continuerons à le faire ça sera le
cas dans le cas dans le cadre des
discussions autour de la proposition de
loi de la majorité qui nous permettra
d'aller plus loin le deuxième c'est la
lutte contre la maltraitance j'en ai
fait ma priorité c'est libérer la parole
c'est renforcer les signalements c'est
renforcer l'accompagnement des familles
c'est tout ce qui aura lieu autour de la
liberté aussi des résidents dans les
EHPAD et puis enfin le lancement des
États généraux que j'ai cité tout à
l'heure il faudra qu'on aille plus loin
également sur la régulation du secteur
et sur sa moralisation merci beaucoup la
parole est à Madame Rachel kéké pour le
groupe la France insoumise merci madame
la présidente Madame la très bien
ministre votre réforme des retraites et
votre méthode pour tenter de la passer
en force manque encore une fois votre
mépris profonde pour les travailleuses
et les travailleurs de ce pays oui je
parle de mépris parce que c'est ça qui a
animé monsieur Macron en 2018 quand il a
décidé de supprimer quatre facteurs de
pénibilité sur 10
ça juste une question monsieur Macron
n'aime pas le mot pénibilité aujourd'hui
vous faites semblant de vous intéresser
aux conditions de travail de gens vous
dites vous allez faire un effort sur la
prise en compte de la pénibilité et des
facteurs que vous avez supprimés comment
instaurer une visite médicale
obligatoire à partir de 61 ans comment
vous le dites ne suffisait certainement
pas il faut rétablir les points
supprimés ce que vous ne faites pas
parce que oui je vis la même chose quand
on est ministre et au fonctionnaires ou
quand on est aesh femme de chambre
livreur ou conducteur de bus avez-vous
la moindre idée de difficultés de ces
métiers essentiels moi je crois que vous
le savez mais vous refusez de le prendre
en compte vous avez pensé à vous avez
pensé pardon allait sauter alors
souffrance
au travail de espérance de vie parce que
oui le travail abîme le corps et on vit
moins longtemps quand on est ouvrier ou
employé la solution n'est pas de
repousser l'âge de départ à la retraite
ça ne justifie même pas financièrement
la solution c'est de c'est de choix une
main baisser le temps de travail
rétablir le point de pénibilité
supprimer et partir à la retraite à 60
ans au final votre réforme de retraite
exprime votre projet de société vous
voulez que les petites travailleurs
jusqu'à vivre dignement de leur retraite
du coup ma chère collègues la parole est
à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion
[Applaudissements]
permet de revenir sur un aspect
important de du projet de loi que nous
défendons avec madame la Première
ministre qui est celui de la prise en
compte de la pénibilité deux éléments de
réponse première élément de réponse il
existe un compte professionnel de
prévention le C2P il a six critères nous
en facilitons le fonctionnement nous
allons abaisser un certain nombre de
seuil actuellement il faut travailler
120 nuits par an pour obtenir des points
ce sera sans nuit il faut travailler 50
fois en équipe successives ça sera 30
nous déplafonnons ce compte nous allons
aussi créer un congé de reconversion et
ainsi le C2P sera plus efficace vous
avez aussi évoqué les trois critères
ergonomiques la posture pénibles le
temps de charge lourdes et l'exposition
en vibration des critères qui sont
extrêmement mesurés difficiles à mesurer
individuellement c'est ce qui avait
expliqué la décision de 2017 et nous
allons faire deux choses la première
chose c'est que nous allons travailler
avec les branches professionnelles pour
que les métiers les plus exposés à ce
risque d'usure professionnelle de
pénibilité puissent bénéficier mettre en
place des accords de prévention et la
sécurité sociale par sa branche accident
du travail maladie professionnelle va
mobiliser un milliard d'euros sur 5 ans
pour financer des actions de prévention
de la pénibilité nous allons aussi avoir
un volet réparation avec un suivi
médical renforcé pas à 61 ans dès 45 ans
régulière pendant toute leur carrière
pour permettre de départ anticipé à ceux
qui effectivement auront été exposés à
l'usure et auront du mal et ne pourront
pas continuer à travailler c'est ce
point d'attention au plus fragile aux
exposés à la pénibilité qui a guidé
l'ensemble de nos travaux avec les
organisations syndicales patronales
comme avec les groupes politiques et
Madame la député beaucoup des questions
que vous avez posées trouveront réponse
dans le texte je suis sûr qu'à la
lecture de celui-ci une fois que le
Conseil des ministres leur a transmis à
l'Assemblée vous trouverez dans le texte
des réponses à vos inquiétudes
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame Lisa belluco pour le
groupe écologiste
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre en
charge de l'Industrie monsieur le
ministre les Hyères lundi 16 janvier les
habitants à habitants de Seine-Maritime
ont de nouveau connu un accident
industriel d'ampleur un incendiant
important s'est déclaré dans une cellule
d'un entrepôt où était stockée 12250
batteries ou éléments de batterie au
lithium pour ensuite s'étendre à la
cellule voisine de l'entrepôt contenant
70 000 pneus
un incendie ça arrive me direz-vous mais
alors qu'est-ce qui cloche dans ce cas
précis
le problème réside dans l'encadrement
réglementaire de ce stockage le stockage
de batterie lithium ne bénéficie pas
d'une rubrique spécifique dans la
nomenclature des installations classées
pour la protection de l'environnement où
il s'estpe autrement dit un entrepôt de
stockage de batterie lithium est
engagent exactement de la même manière
qu'un entrepôt de même volume stockant
plus de 500 tonnes de carton
ici il s'agit de quelques milliers de
batterie lithium stockés dans un
entrepôt soumis au régime de
l'enregistrement c'est un régime
d'autorisation très voire parfois trop
simplifié sans études d'impact ni étude
de danger complète
alors monsieur le ministre vous et vos
collègues n'avaient que les termes de
réindustrialisation de la France à la
bouche mais ne croyez-vous pas qu'il
faudrait d'abord prendre au sérieux les
enjeux de sécurité industrielle ce liées
à la transition énergétique pour enfin
permettre une réelle industrialisation
sur pour l'environnement et les
populations
l'agitation législative c'est bien pour
la communication mais il faudrait aussi
penser à laisser le temps nécessaire à
vos services pour rédiger les arrêtés
précisant la loi alors pour éviter de
nouvelles catastrophes industrielles et
mieux encadrer la montée en puissance
des nouvelles technologies quand
comptez-vous adapter la réglementation
des installations classées aux enjeux
d'aujourd'hui et là par exemple au
stockage de batterie et d'ailleurs
puisque vous évoquez sans arrêt la
réindustrialisation j'imagine que vous
avez prévu une montée en puissance des
moyens et des postes dédiés à
l'inspection des installations classées
dont le métier est justement d'éviter
les accidents industriels merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
Béchu ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée d'abord j'aimerais vous
remercier sincèrement de souhaiter la
réussite de la réindustrialisation de
notre pays parce que c'est évidemment un
des enjeux essentiels pour réussir une
transition écologique qui soit pas
hypocrite c'est-à-dire qui consiste pas
à baiser nos émissions ici pour
augmenter notre empreinte loin d'ici
ensuite la question de la sécurité
industrielle elle est bien sûr au coeur
de nos préoccupations et vous soulignez
à juste titre la nécessité que nous
avons à mieux circonscrire les risques
et à mieux mesurer la nécessité la
compagnie des activités économiques de
ce point de vue nous avons vécu un drame
à Lubrizol
en septembre 2019 à l'issue duquel deux
trains de mesure ont été pris dans le
courant de l'année 2020
en février puis en septembre parmi
ceux-là un durcissement des règles qui
s'applique au site ICPE y compris à ceux
qui font seulement l'objet d'un
enregistrement
une un renforcement des contrôles et une
augmentation des moyens en termes
d'inspecteur c'est ce que vous appelez
de vos vœux après 50 créations de poste
ces deux dernières années 25 créations
de postes nouvelles vont avoir lieu
c'est 21% d'augmentation des inspections
quand on compare l'année 2022 par
rapport à l'année 2018 et ce chiffre ne
voulons porter à plus 50% dans le même
temps la transparence puisque tous les
rapports sont désormais accessibles
depuis le 1er janvier 2022 dès la
survenance d'un accident la liste des
produits qui étaient à l'intérieur des
entrepôts et rendu public en des termes
qui sont intelligibles pour le public
pour faire en sorte que précisément il
puisse y avoir une capacité à restaurer
la confiance sur ces sujets qui sont
cruciaux pour assurer cette politique de
réinstruction de réindustrialisation
donc merci pour votre question et n'ayez
aucun doute sur le fait que nous
augmentons les moyens nous durcissons
les règles et nous faisons précisément
en sorte d'aller dans ce sens là je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre la parole
est à Madame Claudia Rouault pour
socialiste merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre en mars 2020
à la suite d'une forte mobilisation
sociale marquée par des grèves et des
manifestations d'ampleur d'un passage en
force avec un 49-3 au Parlement et à
l'aube d'une pandémie le projet de
réforme des retraites a été suspendu
depuis 3 ans notre pays a connu une
succession de crise sanitaire choc de la
guerre en Ukraine crise énergétique
pénurie de médicaments et de matières
premières l'inflation ce contexte relayé
non-stop par des médias est anxiogènes
et de nombreux citoyens expriment une
grande lassitude pourtant le 23 juillet
prochain votre exécutif en temps
réamorcer une autre réforme des
retraites elle consiste à reporter l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite à 64 ans
malgré le refus unanime de l'ensemble
des syndicats et son rejet par 7
Français sur 10
votre effort est profondément injuste
car elle cible et salariée les plus
modestes notamment ceux qui ont commencé
à travailler tôt et les travailleurs qui
s'apprêtent à prendre leur retraite un
report unilatéral de l'âge de départ à
la retraite à 65 ans sans mesure de
justice sociale apparaît comme brutal
des inégalités en termes d'espérance de
vie de pénibilité au travail existe
cette réforme est une atteinte au droit
des travailleurs a-t-il en a demandé
tant d'efforts notamment pendant la
crise sanitaire et qui peine à vivre
dignement aujourd'hui en raison de la
hausse des prix madame la Première
ministre trouvez-vous juste de demander
un ouvrier qui travaille dans une
entreprise agroalimentaire dans le froid
en horaire décalé et dont le corps est
usé par la tâche de travailler plus
longtemps entendez-vous la souffrance de
nos compatriotes qui ont déjà donné leur
plus belles années de leur vie à leur
travail et qui aspirent enfin à pouvoir
profiter d'une retraite bien méritée
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion merci madame la députée
un exemple ou une illustration en disant
est-ce que vous trouvez juste qu'un
ouvrier dans un entreprise agricole
agroalimentaire travail plus longtemps
dans le froid et soumis des gestes
répétitifs et bien non c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons à l'issue des
concertations monnaie avec les
organisations syndicales d'abord
modifier le compte personnel de
prévention le compte professionnel de
prévention le C2P pour diminuer le
nombre de nuits que l'on doit travailler
pour faire en sorte que les gestes
répétitifs soient mieux pris en compte
et que le salarié que vous citer un
exemple puisse acquérir plus de points
au titre de la pénibilité et ainsi
partir plus tôt c'est la démonstration
que l'augmentation progressive de l'âge
légal du départ à la retraite que nous
mettons en oeuvre pour insérer
l'équilibre du système est accompagner
de menus de mesures sociales pour te
protéger les plus fragiles ceux qui sont
exposés à les pénibilité ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler plus tôt sur les
carrières longues il y a un dispositif
qui permet un départ anticipé pour ceux
qui ont travaillé avant 20 ans un autre
très peu utilisé pour ceux qui sont
travaillés avant 18 ans nous en créons
un troisième pour ceux qui commencent à
travailler avant 16 ans avant 18 ans
pardonnez-moi je pense notamment aux
apprentis sur chacun des items que vous
avez évoqués nous progressons et nous
avançons des droits pour justement
accompagner et permettre que
collectivement nous puissions travailler
un peu plus rééquilibrer le système de
retraite tout en améliorant et j'en suis
sûr répondre à vos inquiétudes
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
madame la députée oui monsieur le
ministre moi je vous invite à venir
passer une semaine chez moi à la
cooperle dans la de roalimentaire et
vous verrez que quand on leur demande
aujourd'hui de travailler 44 ans 40%
d'entre eux sont inaptes à toute
fonction à 55 56 ans peut-être vous
reverrez un petit peu cette réforme de
retraite
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Didier Paris du
groupe Renaissance merci merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur momise la Justice garde des
sceaux la justice souffre d'une crise
chronique qui désespère ses acteurs et
mine la confiance qui devrait l'unir aux
Français les citoyens sentiment d'une
justice trop lente qui ne prend pas le
temps de les écouter d'une justice
laxiste qui ne prend pas le temps de les
protéger mais vous avez monsieur le
ministre tout comme le président de la
République clairement pris la mesure du
mal en présentant il y a quelques jours
le plan d'action des états généraux de
la justice il ne s'agit pas d'un énième
racommodage mais d'une véritable
ambition opérationnelle et concrète qui
s'accompagne de moyens largement à la
hauteur des enjeux les organisations
professionnelles et syndicales de
magistrats et d'avocats ne semble pas
s'y être trompé et salue avec la
vigilance que l'on doit néanmoins
admettre ces mesures il faut dire que
l'effort est tout bonnement historique
puisque de la trajectoire budgétaire du
ministère aboutira à une augmentation de
60% à l'issue des deux quinquennats ces
montants permettront d'achever la
construction des 15000 places de prison
tout en créant 10 000 emplois
supplémentaires une revalorisation de
tous les métiers de la justice mais vous
avez aussi compris que le budget n'est
pas tout monsieur le ministre raison
pour laquelle votre plan raciste large
en prévoyant une soixantaine de mesures
une organisation nouvelle du ministère
une révolution culturelle par le
développement massif de la médiation en
matière civile ou encore on vous
attaquant à la réforme du code de
procure pénal quand bien même elle se
ferait à droit constant votre plan
soulève de grands espoirs que nous ne
pourrons nous permettre de travailler la
représentation nationale si engagera
on se préservant je l'espère du moins
des postures maximalistes stériles pour
placer la justice à hauteur de la
mission fondamentale qui est la sienne
pouvez-vous monsieur administré nous
apporter les éléments de fond de méthode
et de calendrier qui nous permettront de
faire aboutir avec vous cette grande
ambition pour la France merci à vous
ministre de la justice si madame la
Présidente
mesdames messieurs les députés monsieur
le député Paris 30 ans d'abandon humain
budgétaire et politique ça laisse des
traces et nos compatriotes ont exprimé
qu'en dépit de l'investissement sans
faille de nos magistrats de nos
greffiers de nos personnels
administratifs la justice était trop
lente trop lente et complexe il faut les
entendre et ça nous oblige les
professionnels de terrain qui ont été
consultés disent quant à eux il faut des
moyens supplémentaires il faut une
simplification il faut une organisation
nouvelle il faut les entendre et bien
sûr cela nous oblige les moyens d'abord
qui me soit permis de remercier madame
la Première ministre sa feuille de route
c'est effectivement que nous entendions
les acteurs de terrain voilà ce que l'on
m'a demandé plan d'embauche historique
1500 magistrats de plus 1500 magistrats
nets 1500 greffiers
décontractuels que nous allons
pérenniser et
et je le dis certains n'ont pas voté ici
les budgets justices je pense ORL je
pense à elle les filles voilà pour le
budget au total sur cinq ans c'est 7,5
milliards d'euros de plus que nous
aurons investi et je veux dire que nous
aurons embauché en 5 ans plus de
magistrats quand 20 ans que durant ces
20 dernières années cet engagement
historique prendra forme à travers une
loi de programmation au printemps et des
mesures réglementaires puisque toute la
partie civile ce sont des mesures
réglementaires de quoi s'agit-il il
s'agit de mettre en place la médiation
pour que le juge se recentre sur son
cœur de métier pour que les avocats
aient davantage de possibilités
d'intervenir dans la médiation et pour
que le citoyen se réapproprie sa
décision en matière pénale grand effort
de simplification au-delà des 60 mesures
concrètes merci envisager dans le plan
d'action merci les délais sont divisés
par deux merci
la parole est à Monsieur Antoine
Villedieu pour le groupe rassemblement
national merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur il est 6h45
merci gare du Nord lorsqu’un immigré en
situation irrégulière s'en prend
brutalement aux usagers comment
témoignent les images insupportables où
l'on voit une personne frappée à une
vingtaine de reprises à l'aide d'un
objet contendant ce criminel fait
l'objet de deux au qtf en 2020 et
l'autre en 2022 a été condamné à
plusieurs reprises mais il est toujours
là en France et en liberté le car
l'immigration est une chance pour la
France pour vous mais moi je pense aux
victimes dont Alexandre gardien de la
paix affecté à la police aux frontières
qui a tenté de maîtriser le forcenet à
Manu
le carnage a pris fin grâce à
l'intervention de deux policiers un en
service et un hors-service qui ont fait
usage de leurs armes à feu impactant
l'assaillant à trois reprises dites-moi
dites-moi combien de victimes
devrions-nous pleurer aujourd'hui sont
l'intervention de ses courageux
policiers
une fois de plus
nous payons par le sang d'innocent la
lâcheté des politiques sécuritaires et
migratoires de ces 40 dernières années
vous êtes tous responsables gauche
droite et centre soit par aveuglement
idéologique soit par naïveté ou
peut-être par votre soumission à
Bruxelles
monsieur le ministre entendez-vous dans
nos villes et nos campagnes mugir ses
féroces barbares qui viennent jusque
dans nos gardes poignarder vos fils et
vos compagnes alors aux armes
législatives comprenez bien que nous
n'attendons rien d'autre que la loi afin
que la justice à peureux vélocirons
monsieur le ministre qu'on déciderez
vous d'appliquer les 100% d'exécution de
qtf promesse qu'avaient aussi faite le
président de la République lors de la
campagne en 2017 merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente de Monsieur
député monsieur député la modération de
notre peau me pousse effectivement à
vous répondre non pas sur le même ton
parce que ce serait je crois une insulte
me semble-t-il aux victimes dont rien ne
vous laisse penser monsieur que parmi
certaines d'entre elles certaines soient
également étrangères et je vous
permettrai s'il vous plaît de souligner
de souligner ici que si les policiers
monsieur sont intervenus en civil avec
leur arme c'est grâce à une loi que n'a
pas voté le Front national
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur cette question alors parlons-en lors
de la loi immigration voter les textes
qui permettent aux policiers
d'intervenir et arrêter de faire vos
immigré dans l'hémicycle et soyez
courageux en fin devant les Français
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Alma Dufour pour
le groupe la France insoumise
madame la Première ministre madame la
Présidente plutôt deux fois qu'une trois
ans après l'incendie de Lubrizol un
nouvel accident industriel a frappé ma
circonscription et le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est que nous n'avons rien appris
de nos erreurs un incendie s'est
déclenché hier à 16h30 dans l'entrepôt
de Bolloré logistique à Grand-Couronne
12000 batteries et 70 000 pneus ont
brûlé toute la soirée aucune sirène n'a
retenti et les premiers SMS d'alerte ont
été envoyés 1h45 après le début de
l'accident de nombreuses personnes n'ont
absolument rien reçu des enfants ce sont
donc retrouvés dans la rue à la sortie
de l'école exposé à l'immense nuage de
fumée noire qui ne cessait d'augmenter
après que l'analyse de l'absence de
substances les plus mortelles étaient
conduites la préfecture de
Seine-Maritime a affirmé que cet
accident n'aura absolument aucun impact
à court moyen et long terme sur la santé
des personnes exposées mais l'analyse
d'autres substances est toujours en
cours et les rares études dont on
dispose dans le monde sur les incendies
de batterie lithium montre une toxicité
sévère et déplore justement le manque de
connaissances sur le sujet et qu'en
est-il de l'impact sur la centaine de
pompiers qui ont été exposés plusieurs
heures à l'acide fluorhydrique dégagé
par le foyer nous demandons leur suivi
médical en urgence depuis 2017 Emmanuel
Macron ne sait pas contenter de
supprimer l'exposition au substances
chimiques dangereuses comme critère de
pénibilité de la retraite il a aussi
supprimé 48 postes à l'Institut national
de l'environnement industriel et des
risques bien sûr ça a tout avoir
monsieur giviens malgré nos alertes le
gouvernement a refusé les augmentations
d'effectifs dans le budget 2023 et
malgré ce que vous avez dit Monsieur
Béchu il n'y a qu'un poste et demi en
plus à l'adréal Normandie depuis
Lubrizol voilà les augmentations
d'effectifs nous n'avons toujours pas de
registre locaux des cancers ce qui
permettrait d'évacuer l'incidence
d'évaluer l'incidence réelle des cancers
d'origine industrielle car on ne cherche
pas ce qu'on le ne nous veut pas trouver
n'est-ce pas enfin comment pouvez-vous
justifier d'imposer une ZFE sans
accompagnement social suffisant sur la
métropole de Rouen au nom de la santé de
ses habitants alors que la répète depuis
hier que la combustion de 12000
batteries et de 70
000 pneus pendant 8 heures n'a aucun
impact sur la santé merci ma chère
collègues
paroles et à Monsieur Christophe Béchu
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
du four
d'abord j'aimerais saluer le courage de
la centaine de pompiers qui a été
déployé qui s'est battu jusqu'au milieu
de la nuit pour faire en sorte d'abord
d'éteindre l'incendie qui s'est déclaré
à 16h36 puis la reprise de feu qu'on a
connu à 3 heures du matin
nous avons appris de Lubrizol parce que
dès le début de cette incendie des
moyens pour aller prendre des mesures
sur tout un tas de substances ont été
mis en place dioxyde d'azote monoxyde de
carbone dissulpture d'hydrogène acide
chlorhydrique acide
fluorique tous ces éléments ont été
testés en temps réel avec en temps réel
par les sapeurs-pompiers le suivi de ces
différents éléments dans le même temps
nous avons par mesure de précaution
laisser des balises de sursis une à
Elbeuf une au Zénith de Rouen une aussi
à Saint-Étienne du Rouvray des analyses
ont été conduites et poussées dans des
laboratoires et alors que ces analyses
disent que nous n'avons pas d'éléments
vous vous partez du principe que quoi
qu'il arrive puisqu'il y a une fumée et
qu'elle est d'origine industrielle il y
a mensonge il y a un souci vous devez
mieux connaître les choses que les
experts vous devez être beaucoup plus
puissants que les pompiers je ne
comprends pas comment on joue sur les
peurs par rapport à un dispositif sur
lequel l'État les inspecteurs l'adréal
on conduit l'ensemble de ces mesures le
bureau enquête accident et sur place à
ma demande pour déterminer l'origine du
sinistre et les raisons pour lesquelles
nous en sommes là mais franchement allez
tweeter pendant l'événement pour inciter
les gens en laissant penser qu'on est
face à un risque imminent au mépris de
ce que disent au mépris de ce que disent
les autorités ça n'est pas responsable
madame Dufour ça n'est pas responsable
trouver un autre moyen de faire des
abonnés sur Twitter je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la parole est à Monsieur David topiac
pour le groupe liberté indépendant
outre-mer et territoire
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre délégué chargé de
la transition numérique et des
télécommunications
l'annonce par la poste de la suppression
du timbre rouge provoque une grande
inquiétude si le constat d'une baisse du
volume de courrier réel cette décision
basée sur la seule motivation économique
de rentabilité mais qu'on est toutefois
l'impact qui en résulte pour les usagers
avec la dématérialisation des envois
cette réforme inflige en particulier au
territoire ruraux et ultramarins une
double peine en ne tenant pas compte des
centaines de zones blanches sans réseau
mobile ou des biens internet
elle ne tient pas compte non plus de la
facture numérique qui affecte toute une
partie de la population et en priorité
les personnes âgées et les plus
précaires selon l'Insee plus de 13
millions de Français sont concernés par
ce problème
elle pose également le problème du
secret de la correspondance sera
désormais impossible l'envoi de chèque
ou de feuilles de soins à la sécurité
sociale de manière
urgente numériser et déshumaniser c'est
autant de coups de boutoirs qui
éloignent petit à petit l'état du
citoyen déjà impacté dans leur quotidien
par le démantèlement des biens
essentiels l'énergie la poste les
services publics la mobilité la santé or
maintenir notre cohésion sociale sans
laisser monter colère et désespoir
nécessite de ne pas ajouter de la
fracture à la fracture
la disparition de ce thème rouge pose
cette question de la place de la
ruralité et de l'outre-mer dans
l'élaboration des politiques publiques
le 9 septembre dernier le gouvernement
attribuait un million d'euros à 200
chercheurs dans le but d'analyser les
grands enjeux auxquels vont faire face
les territoires ruraux je peux vous
répondre que la préservation des
services publics du lien social et la
réduction de cette fracture numérique
sont une des priorités
allez-vous enfin prendre en
considération les besoins des
populations à préservant le doubusage de
cette réforme je remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Olivia
Grégoire un ministre délégué chargé des
petites et moyennes entreprises du
commerce de l'artisanat et du tourisme
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
vous interrogez le gouvernement sur les
évolutions de la politique courrier de
la poste et je souhaite vous apporter
quelques précisions d'abord vous dire
Monsieur le Député Utopia que les
timbres rouge acheté avant le 1er
janvier 2023 reste parfaitement
utilisable après cette date vous dire
ensuite que la Poste a constaté mais
vous l'avez aussi mentionné le monsieur
le député topiaque le fait que on
assistait à une évolution importante des
usages du courrier et nos concitoyens
ont fait bouger leurs habitudes avec 45
ans voix prioritaire en moyenne par an
et par ménage en 2010 contre 5 désormais
en 2021 ce constat qui est frappant il
entraîne une évolution de l'offre via la
mise en place de la île être rouge mais
ne minimise pas la présence du facteur 6
jours sur 7 pour l'ensemble des
activités de distribution de la poste et
sur tout le territoire
je veux aussi partager avec vous que la
Poste maintient par ailleurs une offre
courrier fiable rapide avec l'aide
service plus et la lettre verte qu'on
connaît tous arrivant à destination
respectivement 2 et 3 jours après
l'envoi vous avez mentionné monsieur
utopiak avec précision le fait que
numériser ne devait pas se faire au
détriment de ne pas déshumaniser c'est
pour ça que les agents de la Poste
continuent d'accompagner dans chacun des
bureaux tous les usagers qui auraient
besoin d'un envoi prioritaire dans le
cas où il serait en difficulté avec le
numérique dans le cas où il ne pourrait
pas envoyer le courrier de chez eux
c'est un engagement fort de la poste il
s'agit d'une transformation importante
je le conçois qui s'adapte aussi aux
nouvelles habitudes des français vous
l'avez mentionné et qui garantit à tous
les niveaux de service qui soient
physiques ou dématérialisés vous dire
dans les quelques secondes qui me
restent que le motif économique n'est
pas le seul et que d'ici 2030 avec cette
mesure et le développement de la illette
rouge la Poste économisera plus tonnes
de CO2 par an 25% d'économies de carbone
sur son bilan je vous remercie merci
beaucoup madame la ministre la parole
est à Monsieur Philippe Pradal pour le
groupe horizon merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre délégué chargé des
petites et moyennes entreprises du
commerce de l'artisanat et du tourisme
la lampe la loi pacte en 2019 a mis en
place un guichet unique permettant aux
entreprises de réaliser l'ensemble des
formalités juridiques pour assurer leur
vie courante en remplacement d'une
multitude d'acteurs cette simplification
qui était attendue par les entreprises
doit être saluée et soutenu au mois de
juillet 2020 c'est l'INPI qui a été
désigné comme opérateur en vue de mettre
en place ce guichet unique qui a pris
une période de test en 2022 à réaliser
et a pu constater un certain nombre de
dysfonctionnements qui ont conduit au
mois de décembre 2022 à l'activation de
la procédure dite de secours réactivant
la présence de multiples opérateurs
pour se faire à ce jour et malgré les
efforts importants réalisés par
l'ensemble des acteurs qui interviennent
sur ce secteur les dysfonctionnements
persistent nuisant ainsi à l'agilité à
la réactivité dont les entreprises
doivent être capables de faire preuve
dans une période qui peut être difficile
et pour laquelle les formalités
juridiques sont souvent nécessaires pour
assurer la protection des entreprises
des emplois et de leur dirigeants madame
la ministre je sollicite donc de votre
part des précisions sur les mesures qui
sont envisagées pour permettre la mise
en place de ce guichet unique qui est
très attendu des entreprises de leurs
conseils et qui rend un service utile
merci
merci beaucoup la parole est à Madame
Olivia Grégoire ministre délégué chargé
des petites et moyennes entreprises du
commerce de l'artisanat et du tourisme
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député Pradal vous m'interrogez sur le
guichet unique et aussi sur le registre
national des entreprises instituées par
la loi pacte votée dans cette émission
le 22 mai 2019
un seul Centre de Formalités au lieu de
6 vous l'avez mentionné un seul
formulaire au lieu de 56 un guichet
numérique au lieu de 70% de démarches en
papier
une gratuité d'accès aux données du
registre national des entreprises oui
c'est un effort de rationalisation de
simplification de lisibilité majeure qui
a prévalu dans cette décision de du
ministre de l'économie de maintenir la
date limite instituée par le législateur
il y a maintenant trois ans le ministre
de l'Économie Bruno Le Maire aurait pu
décaler mais l'engagement a été tenu et
au premier janvier 2022 le calendrier
tenu près de 110000 peut-être que ça
peut être intéressant de partager avec
vous ces données sans dix mille
formalités de création il y avait été
enregistré à la veille de la bascule le
portail de l'INPI a pu intégrer les
formalités de modification dès le
premier septembre 2022 et quel est le
premier constat 15 jours après l'entrée
en vigueur de ce guichet unique et de
cette réforme oui il y a encore des
difficultés j'y reviens mais plus de 80
000 formalités de création ont été
effectués en deux semaines c'est
d'autant que sur l'ancien mode sur tout
au long de 2022 en dépit d'une attaque
informatique que vous n'avez pas
mentionné mais que je tiens quand même à
rappeler j'ai à cœur de dire aussi que
le site a tenu bon et que le système
d'information n'a pas été mis à mal
l'attaque a clairement ralenti rendu
indisponible les formalités relatives au
modifications des formalités non pas de
création là dessus on doit s'améliorer
je tiens à vous dire dans les secondes
restants que Bruno Le Maire a engagé une
discussion assez ferme avec l'INPI pour
améliorer dès les prochaines semaines ce
qui doit encore être amélioré sur les
modifications sur les créations ça
fonctionne le travail sera réalisé d'ici
à la fin du mois de février c'est un
engagement du ministre de l'économie
merci Madame la Ministre la parole est à
madame Gisèle le Louis pour le
rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre délégué
Jean-Noël Barrault alors que vous
demandez tous les jours aux Français de
se serrer la ceinture force est de
constater que les services publics ne
sont pas à la hauteur de l'effort
financier des contribuables français un
rapport du Sénat de 2020 tirait pourtant
déjà la sonnette d'alarme constatant que
les centres des impôts s'éloignaient que
la dématérialisation engendrait des
coûts abominables que tout devenait à la
charge des collectivités et finalement
rien que l'accès aux soins se dégradait
récemment la poste en plus d'augmenter
le prix du timbre a pris la décision de
réinventer le fax pour pallier à ces
problèmes de distribution s'éloignant
toujours plus des gens en particulier
des personnes âgées et créant une grande
insécurité sociale dans les
Bouches-du-Rhône les gardanelles sont
inquiets de la nouvelle expérimentation
de la poste de changer chaque jour de
l'étranger en fonction du courrier à
répartir dans les boîtes aux lettres là
ce sera un jour sur deux
pourquoi pas mais après ce sera une fois
par semaine et après faudra aller
chercher soi-même son courrier
à Marseille les 2500 habitants de la
Bricarde ne reçoit plus de colis depuis
7 ans ni lettre depuis près d'un an la
Poste a pris cette décision pour ses
agents face à l'insécurité grandissante
de cette zone entre trafic de staffie
et enlèvement en plein jour et oui
l'écroulement de nos services publics à
Marseille est aussi lié à un problème
d'insécurité à force de retirer les
services publics dans les quartiers nord
les habitants ne se sentent pas des
citoyens part entière mais des citoyens
de seconde zone quand les services
fuient ou ferme c'est l'État qui fuit
face à la disparition des pouvoirs
publics à Marseille les habitants
s'organisent comme dimanche sur le
boulevard National l'association un jour
un déchet remplacer les services en les
ramassant eux-mêmes sur le front de la
cité des campanules les habitants
résistent eux-mêmes en montant la garde
avec les vigiles de bailleur pour
déloger les dealers à leur charge face à
l'absence de l'État alors monsieur le
ministre que comptez-vous pour garantir
l'accessibilité aux services merci
beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Stanislas
Guérini ministre de la fonction publique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
le Louis
votre question porte sur la présence des
services publics sur nos territoires et
à travers votre question vous
sous-entendez au fond qu'il y aura un
désinvestissement des services publics
sur le territoire ce qui est absolument
le contraire de la politique qui est
menée par ce gouvernement comment
pouvez-vous dire que nous des
investissons les services publics quand
au contraire nous ouvrons des espaces
France service 2600 espaces seront
services ouverts sur le territoire de la
République selon l'engagement du
président de la République désormais à
moins de 30 minutes de chacun de nos
concitoyens il y a un service public
disponible matérialisé avec des hommes
et des femmes que je veux saluer
aujourd'hui qui rendent justement ces
services publics comment vous pouvez
vous dire que cette majorité des investi
les services publics quand au contraire
nous réengageons et nous réinvestissons
massivement vous avez parlé de sécurité
madame dans les postes de policiers
10000 encore sur le quinquennat à
travers des budgets que vous ne votez
pas et que le rassemblement national ne
pas alors contrairement à tous les
discours entendus et toutes les
agitations d'hémicycles nous nous
agissons justement pour réinvestir dans
les services publics
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est au président brotherson pour
le groupe GDR
merci merci madame la présidente madame
la Première ministre vu de Matignon ou
de l'Elysée on a souvent l'impression
que les outre-mer c'est l'endroit de la
carte postale c'est les plus beaux
lagons les plus belles plages c'est
Arianespace c'est 98% de la biodiversité
c'est tout ça mais retournons cette
carte postale et regardons ce qu'il y a
à l'envers de la carte postale et on
trouve les populations les plus pauvres
de France on trouve une espérance de vie
inférieure de six ans à celle de
l'Hexagone on trouve des pensions de
retraite qui sont 15% à 17% inférieurs
en moyenne à celles qui sont touchées
dans l'Hexagone on trouve un taux de
pauvreté chez les retraités qui est lui
aussi beaucoup plus élevé que ce qu'on
trouve ici on trouve des conditions en
emploi des femmes qui sont déplorables
on trouve une précarité de l'emploi et
des carrières hachées trois fois
supérieur à celle qu'on trouve dans
l'Hexagone
on trouve également des victimes du
chlore des cônes et des victimes des
conséquences des essais nucléaires dont
les carrières seront soit arrêtées parce
qu'elles décèdent soit parce qu'elle
devient Invalides alors à l'aune de
l'examen de ce projet de réforme par le
Conseil d'État et j'ai deux questions
relativement simple est-ce que le
dossier qui a été transmis au Conseil
d'État contient comme on pourrait s'y
attendre une sérieuse étude d'impact sur
les effets de cette réforme sur les
outre-mer c'est ma première question et
ma deuxième question comme vous l'avez
annoncé pour l'Hexagone quels sont les
concertations préalables quel est le
dialogue quelle est la discussion
collégiale qui a eu lieu avec les corps
intermédiaires les exécutifs locaux et
les élus je vous remercie je vous
remercie
la parole
est à Monsieur Olivier Véran ministre en
charge de du renouveau démocratique et
porte-parole du gouvernement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Robertson merci pour votre question
d'abord on peut tomber d'accord sur un
certain nombre de diagnostic que vous
avez posé s'agissant de l'impact sur la
santé d'un certain nombre de paramètres
dont les taux de présence de fréquence
sont spécifiquement plus élevés
d'ailleurs dans certains territoires
ultramarins et qui peuvent avoir un
impact sur l'espérance de vie donc
j'essaie de comprendre le sens de votre
question si je comprends bien c'est que
vous dites étant donné que l'espérance
de vie peut-être différente et le le
milieu professionnel peut-être différent
dans certains territoires ultramarins
serait-il bon ou dons d'adapter la
future réforme des retraites pour les
territoires ultramarins c'est cela bien
quelques éléments de réponse à vous à
vous donner comme ça à la volée
tout d'abord toutes les réformes des
retraites depuis le système depuis la
création du système de la sécurité
sociale ont été appliqués de manière
uniforme sur l'ensemble du territoire de
la République que ce soit en métropole
ou dans les territoires ultramarins la
durée de travail et la même par exemple
dans les Antilles en Guyane à la Réunion
qu'en métropole donc il n'y a pas lieu
spontanément de penser fonctionner
différemment cette fois-ci puisque tout
le système de travail ainsi que le
système de financement d'ailleurs par
les cotisations et les versements des
pensions de retraite a été établie pour
fonctionner de manière uniforme sur
l'ensemble du territoire vous
m'interrogez ensuite interrogez le
gouvernement suite sur l'état des
concertations avec l'ensemble des élus
notamment des élus des territoires
écoutez nous sommes rentrés à l'issue de
la phase de concertation se conduite
sous l'égide de la première ministre et
du ministre en charge du travail avec
les syndicats et partenaires sociaux
dans cette phase d'échange avec la
population française pour leur expliquer
pourquoi nous voulons cette réforme des
retraites pourquoi elle est nécessaire
et pourquoi nous avons mis tout un tas
d'amortisseurs il y a des échanges que
vous aurez dans le cas du Parlement et
vous en serez présent et représentant de
la Polynésie française au sein de
l'Assemblée nationale française
de pouvoir modifier si vous le souhaitez
amender le texte en espérant que les
conditions d'examen du texte le
permettent d'ailleurs et ensuite il y a
des échanges de tout va à des réunions
publiques sont organisées dans les
territoires avec les élus de tous les
territoires mais il en va de la même
manière pour les territoires ultramarins
pour les territoires de la métropole
cette réforme des retraites elle
s'appliquera à tous les Français à tous
les français puisqu'il en va encore une
fois de l'avenir du système des
retraites dont bénéficie la totalité des
Français
[Musique]
merci merci pour votre réponse monsieur
le ministre mais c'est je pense
justement cette uniformité c'est là où
le bât blesse parce qu'on a depuis la
réforme de 2003 un beau principe dans
notre Constitution qui est celui de la
spécificité législative après tout alors
aujourd'hui nous proposer un One Size
Fitz all excuser pardon my French ça n'a
pas de sens en 2023 je crois que les
conditions sont différentes dans les
outre-mer et dans l'Hexagone et qu'il
faut en tenir compte et il faut discuter
il faut dialoguer
la parole est à Monsieur Hubert Hope
pour le groupe démocrate
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires monsieur le ministre le
tribunal administratif de Strasbourg
vient d'annuler l'autorisation donnée
par le préfet du Haut-Rhin de poursuivre
les travaux de confinement des déchets
de stokamine entreposés depuis plus de
20 ans dans les galeries d'anciennes
mines cette décision du tribunal fait
suite aux nombreuses requêtes des
associations mais aussi de nos élus de
la collectivité européenne d'Alsace une
nouvelle décision judiciaire conforme
aux précédentes qui nous rappelle la
gravité du dossier et le degré élevé de
responsabilité de ceux qui ont enfouis
sous la nappe phréatique d'Alsace la
plus grande d'Europe des déchets
toxiques qui menacent notre ressource en
eau la particularité de ce dossier
réside dans notre incapacité à pouvoir
garantir qu'en cas de confinement
définitif des déchets il n'y aura pas de
pollution la complexité du guyère minier
héritée de l'exploitation de la potasse
associée au caractère sismiques de la
région rendent quasi impossible que les
laboration de scénarios prédictifs si on
rajoute à la nature toxique complexe des
déchets leur effet cocktail en cas de
contact avec les eaux il est impossible
aujourd'hui d'écarter la gravité d'une
pollution une seule chose est certaine
prévue d'ailleurs par l'ensemble des
études c'est l'embrayage des galeries et
donc la mise en contact des déchets et
de l'eau infiltrée depuis la surface la
parole de l'État est en jeu l'État
s'était engagé à la réversibilité de ce
stockage souterrain aujourd'hui il
s'agit d'en finir avec l'immobilisme
dans lequel s'est réfugié
l'administration car tous les ministres
se sont successivement prononcés de la
même manière pour le confinement
renonçant à tous des stockages tous ont
été désavoués par la justice monsieur le
ministre l'urgente est l'urgence est à
déstocker et à la lumière de cette
nouvelle décision du tribunal
pouvez-vous répondre à cette attente
unanime celle d'un déstockage de ces
déchets dangereux que la population
alsacienne et son avenir mérite plus que
jamais
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs le député monsieur
le député
ce dossier
je dois dire qu'il y en a des complexes
mais celui-là
on est effectivement sur un sujet qui
remonte à 99 après la fin de
l'exploitation d'une mine de fer on a
monté le projet dans cette fin des
années 90 d'aller y enfuir des centaines
de milliers de tonnes de déchets et
après qu'on en est rentré à peu près 50
000 un incendie en 2002 a conduit le
processus à s'arrêter
vous l'avez dit de surcroît avant même
c'est incendie au moment où cette mine
pour l'environnement a été lancée le la
manière de le présenter c'était
d'indiquer que le processus pourrait
être réversible sans que le maintien
définitif ne soit d'ailleurs totalement
exclu dans les documents qui avaient été
présentés à l'époque
il a fallu
attendre que
Ségolène Royal décide d'aller extraire
les déchets les plus solubles le mercure
ce qui était les plus susceptibles
d'entrer dans la nappe pour
qu'effectivement les choses bougent mais
à l'issue de cette extraction des
déchets les plus solides des plus
solubles pardon la décision qui a été
prise ça a été de confiner le reste et
ce confinement il a été confirmé de
manière continue depuis en particulier
parce que les parois de la mine se
referme sur elle-même progressivement et
que pour éviter les contaminations que
vous décrivez il faut calfeutrer il faut
boucher il faut confiner cette mide et
nous savons aujourd'hui qu'en 2027 ce
phénomène de convergence sera terminé le
sujet c'est est-ce que dans le temps qui
est devant nous nous avons la
possibilité de procéder à d'autres des
stockages j'ai demandé à mes services y
compris avant la décision de justice de
tirer tout ça au clair le DGPR sera dans
quelques jours sur site et au début du
mois de février avec les élus alsaciens
je vous recevrai pour poser les choses
sur la table mais je le dis très
clairement le confinement est
inéluctable nous il n'y a pas
d'alternative et penser qu'un déstockage
total serait possible ce serait mentir
aux gens merci Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Jérôme Nury pour
le groupe les républicains
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre l'industrie vendredi dernier le
tribunal de commerce de Lyon a prononcé
la liquidation judiciaire du groupe
place du marché expo par gel qui emploie
plus de 1900 salariés sur 127
plateformes en France le site le plus
important en termes d'emploi est celui
d'Argentan dans l'Orne avec près de 90
salariés vous imaginez bien que cette
liquidation est un véritable coup de
massue à la fois pour les personnels qui
voient leur vie bouleverser en quelques
jours et à la fois pour le territoire
d'Argentan qui a encore une économie
fragile suite à une désigne de
réalisation massive dans les années 2000
à l'initiative du préfet de l'Orne une
réunion réunissant le mandataire les
représentants du personnel les élus
locaux Pôle Emploi les services de
l'État a été organisé hier afin de faire
le point sur les mesures mises en place
collectivement et individuellement pour
les 1900 salariés EPSE dans le cas de la
procédure plan grand licenciement va
donc être déclenché toutefois il a été
précisé lors de ce rendez-vous qui
n'était pas prévu d'indemnisation supra
légale cette nouvelle a été très mal
vécue par les salariés qui se sentent
trahis et humilié alors qu'ils ont fait
des efforts considérables pour relever
l'entreprise même lorsque le tribunal a
constaté qu'il n'y avait pas de
repreneur les salariés ont jusqu'à la
fin et malgré la fermeture annoncée
préparer les produits classés et mis sur
palette afin qu'ils puissent être
valorisés financièrement par le
liquidateur il est donc impératif
monsieur le ministre de trouver un moyen
de réparer cette injustice et d'obtenir
des indemnités supra légales pour ses
salariés qui en plus vont certainement
être les premiers à être concernés par
la réduction des indemnités chômage dans
le temps pour cela nous avons besoin que
le gouvernement fasse pression sur les
actionnaires afin qu'ils abondent soit
le PSE soit la trésorerie pour verser
ses indemnités cette demande est
d'autant plus légitime que les deux
actionnaires principaux Léo et Patrick
va Dorian sont notamment à la tête de
l'enseigne florissante grand frais qui
dégage suffisamment de bénéfices depuis
des années pour permettre au moins ce
geste vis-à-vis de leur 1900
collaborateurs qui laissent aujourd'hui
sur le carreau monsieur le ministre
pouvons-nous compter sur le gouvernement
et sur vous pour aider les sites
notamment dans l'Orne réindustrialiser
et pour accompagner les salariés et
essayer d'obtenir ces indemnités suivra
légales je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Roland Lescure ministre délégué
chargé de l'Industrie merci madame la
Présidente merci monsieur le député
Jérôme du riz pour votre question qui me
permet d'aborder la situation vous
l'avez dit extrêmement difficile de
l'entreprise tout par gel une entreprise
qui date de plus de 75 ans puisqu'elle a
été créée en 1947 et dont
malheureusement la liquidation
judiciaire a été prononcée il y a
quelques jours le 11 janvier dernier
vous le savez nous avons aidé cette
entreprise en mois de juin dernier nous
avions
adopté un plan un prêt pardon garanti
par l'état de plus de 35 millions
d'euros avec l'actionnaire d'ailleurs
pour essayer de restructurer la
entreprise et notamment d'accélérer la
transition vers le Web puisque vous
savez que cette entreprise fonctionnait
par du téléphone et de la livraison à
domicile malheureusement puis tout à
fait en phase avec les méthodes
d'aujourd'hui malheureusement ce virage
il faut le reconnaître a été un échec
l'entreprise a été liquidé vous avez
raison de nous dire qu'aujourd'hui la
priorité absolue doit être
l'accompagnement des salariés
premier point important le ministre du
plein emploi Olivier du socle a décidé
d'affecter une procédure particulière
vous l'avez mentionné dans votre
intervention qui permettra un cabinet
spécialisé d'accompagner chaque salarié
dans la formation et dans le retour à
l'emploi c'est essentiel pour vous
l'avez dit un plan un plan de
liquidation qui a un impact social très
important deux sur la partie financière
malheureusement les procédures sont très
encadrées vous le savez tout ça se place
dans le cadre de tribunal de commerce
qui ne peut pas bonifier les PSE et qui
est extrêmement contraint par le système
qu'on appelle AGS assurance Galanti des
salaires pour autant vous l'avez dit les
actionnaires peuvent décider eux-mêmes
de bonifier le PSE je peux vous
confirmer que l'administrateur
judiciaire a écrit aux actionnaires pour
leur demander de le faire et j'ai
demandé à mes services d'en faire de
même la balle est dans leur camp et
j'espère qu'ils seront répondre à ces
deux interpellations merci monsieur le
député merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Freddy
certains pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente
ma question à laquelle j'associe le
député David Valence s'adresse à
monsieur le garde des sceaux monsieur le
garde des sceaux mes chers collègues
nous avons tous été bouleversés par la
disparition du jeune Lucas le 7 janvier
dernier et je tiens ici à rendre hommage
à ce garçon de 13 ans victime de
harcèlement en raison de son orientation
sexuelle à cet instant mes pensées vont
à sa famille et ses proches
même si l'enquête est toujours en cours
ce tragique évènement nous a rappelé
combien la lutte contre le harcèlement
doit être l'une de nos priorités petits
et grands hommes ou femmes personnalité
publique ou non comme a pu le rappeler
la chanteuse Hoshi beaucoup trop de
Françaises et de français et en
particulier nos jeunes sont confrontés à
ce fléau que ce soit à l'école ou en
ligne notre implication doit être totale
pour y faire face depuis plus de 5 ans
maintenant nos députés de la majorité
faisons de la lutte contre le
harcèlement et en particulier au
cyber-harcèlement un de nos principaux
combats
je pense notamment à la proposition de
loi visant à lutter contre la haine en
ligne au projet de loi confortant le
respect des principes de la République
mais également au dispositif de
sensibilisation mise en place au sein
des établissements scolaires après la
sensibilisation vient le temps de
l'action permettez-moi de rappeler que
c'est ce gouvernement qui pour la
première fois a su consacrer une part
forte de l'action de la justice à cette
question il nous reste évidemment encore
beaucoup pas faire et je vous sais
Monsieur le Ministre pleinement engagé
sur ce sujet ainsi pourriez-vous
préciser quels sont les moyens mis à
disposition de la justice afin de
pouvoir lutter efficacement contre le
cyber-harcèlement je vous remercie merci
Eric Dupond-Moretti garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député certains
le suicide de cet enfant de 13 ans
nous laisse sans voix et d'ailleurs les
mots sont dérisoires j'ai comme vous une
pensée mue bien sûr pour sa famille vous
savez vous l'avez rappelé une enquête
judiciaire est en cours et naturellement
je ne peux pas la commenter en revanche
ce que je peux dire c'est que le
harcèlement a raison notamment de
l'orientation sexuelle l'homophobie ne
strictement rien à faire dans notre
République et qu'il faut que tous
ensemble nous luttions contre ces
phénomènes dès mon arrivée au ministère
j'ai mis en place le pôle n en ligne
dans la foulée de la loi avia vous le
savez c'est 1000 procédures qui ont
connu un véritable succès les plus
connus d'entre elles c'est l'affaire
Mila bien sûr l'affaire de Miss Provence
qui elle avait été harcelée à raison du
fait qu'elle est juive c'est aussi
l'affaire Eddy De Pretto et c'est
actuellement l'affaire de l'artiste
Hoshi qui est poursuivi par on sait
qu'elle vindique raison de ses prises de
position alors nous allons fêter bientôt
les deux ans du pôle et en ligne qui
travaille d'ailleurs avec le pôle farose
vous le savez je remercie ici le
ministre de l'Intérieur nous avons fait
aussi en sorte que ces affaires puissent
être jugées en comparution immédiate les
deux ans arrivent j'irai très
prochainement au pôle n en ligne pour
savoir quels sont les améliorations que
nous pouvons apporter je veux dire
d'ailleurs à ceux qui nous écoutent que
il faut déposer plainte le justice ne
peut pas s'auto saisir et souvent elle
ne n'est pas au courant de ce qui se
passe pour le reste bien sûr nous allons
renforcer ces dispositifs je veux dire
également à tous ceux qui nous écoutent
que l'anonymat derrière l'ordinateur
ça suffit et que les tweets peuvent
blesser et qu'ils peuvent tuer et que
nous saurons tous très vigilants pour ne
pas que ces phénomènes se reproduisent
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Madame Sylvie Ferrer pour
le groupe LFI
ante monsieur le ministre merci madame
le Président de Monsieur le Ministre
chers collègue cet été collectivement
nous avons décidé de répondre à une
demande essentielle des personnes en
situation de handicap nous avons
ensemble hormis un élu de la majorité
votez la déconjugalisation de
l'allocation adulte handicapé et permis
par la même de mettre fin à des
situations injustes de dépendance au
sein des couples il y a également été
décidé une revalorisation de 4% de cette
aide pour venir compléter la mesure on
ne peut que s'en réjouir toutefois il
est nécessaire de rappeler que un le
plafond de l'allocation adulte handicapé
et de 956 euros et qu'il reste donc
inférieur au seuil de pauvreté de la
revalorisation accordée est inférieure
au taux d'inflation dans notre pays 3 la
déconjugalisation ne prendra effet qu'à
partir du 1er octobre 2023 il nous faut
il nous faut aller plus loin et agir
même très dès maintenant
monsieur le ministre le gouvernement a
évoqué des difficultés administratives
qui expliqueraient le délai de mise en
application
pourtant alors que nous n'avons pas
encore voté le texte vous prévoyez de
déjà de mettre en œuvre votre réforme
des retraites dès l'été prochain je suis
toujours surprise de la facilité de la
rapidité avec laquelle ce gouvernement
ponctionne les classes populaires et les
classes moyennes d'un autre pays et de
la difficulté qu'il a à redistribuer au
plus fragile de nos concitoyens des
concitoyens monsieur le ministre je peux
faire le choix de vous faire confiance
je peux faire le choix de croire qu'on
ne peut raccourcir ce délai malgré votre
volonté mais c'est à vous aujourd'hui en
répondant à ma question de me montrer
que je peux avoir confiance donner un
effet rétroactif à la mesure que nous
avons prise et des dès maintenant nos
concitoyens et concitoyens en situation
de handicap monsieur le ministre puis-je
avoir confiance allez-vous le faire
la parole est à Madame Geneviève
dariussec ministre délégué chargé des
personnes handicapées désolé madame la
présidente Madame la député Sylvie
Ferrer
bon votre question
remet presque en cause ce qui a été voté
ici c'est à dire une mise en application
de cette mesure en octobre 23 et vous
savez pourquoi nous avons vous avez vous
au Parlement votez cette mise en
application en octobre 23 c'est très
simple si nous n'avions pas fait il y
aurait 50000 personnes perdantes dans
l'application de cet âge des conjugués
alors nous avons organisé un temps
d'échange avec Jean-Christophe combe
avec tous les députés les groupes
parlementaires
en décembre dernier qui nous ont permis
de mesurer que d'abord l'application de
cette loi nous étions dans les temps
aujourd'hui nous avons voté des décrets
nous avons pardon signé des décrets qui
ont été publiés le 28 décembre dernier
qui permettent de mettre en oeuvre cette
qui permettront de mettre en oeuvre cet
âge c'est-à-dire un mode de calcul qui
sera automatique pour et sans démarche
particulière et en mode de calcul qui
permettront au perdant de cette réforme
s'il n'y avait rien eu de garder la
déconjugalisation et cela sera fait
automatiquement par la Caisse nationale
d'allocations familiale donc vous voyez
ce sujet est complexe parce que les
situations sont très diverses la mise en
œuvre numérique par la Caisse
d'Allocations Familiales demande aussi
un temps important d'architecture du
système numérique parce que c'est un
système qui n'est pas un système
classique pour les caisses d'allocations
familiales ou toutes les prestations
sont conjuguées donc vous le voyez ce ne
sont que des problèmes techniques qui
nous ont conduit à proposer cette date
du 1er octobre et je veux rassurer tout
le monde cette date et bien elle sera
respectée
merci Madame la Ministre madame la
députée j'ai ma réponse je ne peux donc
pas vous faire confiance
je vous remercie la séance de questions
au Gouvernement est terminée la séance
est suspendue